sziasztok a következő vendégeim csilla
és brigitta a digitális biztonság
témáját fogjuk majd körbejárni fogunk
beszélni majd a közösségi médiah
használatról a jogi kihívásokról amik
felmerülnek így a közösségi média
kapcsán valamint az eszközhasználatról
és a számítógépes játékokról is én mint
programozó azt hittem hogy eleget tudok
én a a digitális biztonságról mivel
eszközöket használok nap mint nap rá
kellett jöjjek hogy mégsem hogy mint
szülő tanulnom kell folyamatosan és
nyitott kell legyek néhány alapelvet
megfogalmaztunk közösen egy nagyon
izgalmas intenzív beszélgetés volt
úgyhogy tartsatok velünk és ne
felejtsetek el
[Zene]
feliratkozni köszöntöm a kedves nézőket
a mai napi téma egy nagyon izgalmas téma
számomra a digitális biztonságról fogunk
beszélgetni lázár csilla a vendégem
valamint szilágyi balázs brigitta
üdvözöllek titeket szia szia köszönjük a
meghívást röviden bemutatkoznátok-e hogy
hogy hol dolgozt mivel foglalkoztok és
miért beszélünk a digitális biztonságról
a a mai témából is adódik hogy akkor a
legfontosabb meg hát amúgy is
legfontosabb állapotbeli tulajdonságom
az hogy három gyermekes anya vagyok a
tínédzser korban levő kettő gyermekem é
egy fiatal felnőtt a emellett a szintén
a témaszempontjából releváns hogy én
tanár vagyok alap képzettségemet
végzettségemet és lelki hivat ásat
tekintve elég sok éve már nem iskolai
körülmények között hanem nonformális
körülmények között végzünk oktatást ebbe
ugye bőven belefér a felnőtt oktatás is
a szülői workshopok a digitális szülői
workshopok amit brigittával közösen
szoktunk vezetni illetve hát egy a
spektrumoktatási központot egy civil
szervezetet oktatási célú civil
szervezetet vezetek már sok éve és velük
próbáljuk követni egy kicsit hogy mire
is volna szükség itt a szük tágabb
régióban amit a amit a közoktatás nem
feltétlen vagy nem azonnal tud
szolgáltatni egy gyors kérdés most a
román oktatási
rendszerben van erre külön a digitális
biztonságra külön tantárgy amit része a
tik tanterveknek ahogy a gyerekek
mondják tehát a számító az
informatika és
számítógéphasználat tanterveknek de
nyilván a a román oktatási rendszer
szokása szerint ezek a tantervek nagyon
lassan frissülnek a tankönyvek meg még
inkább az iskolai számítógépes
taneszközök meg egészen a legutóbbi
időkig nagyon elavultak voltak tehát
azért mondom ezt mert most reménykedünk
hogy a penererével most több iskolában
lesz megfelelő technika és a gyerekek
nem érzik már relevánsnak azt ami ott
elhangzik nevetnek a videókon amit a
tanárnénék a legjobb szándékkal
bejátszanak a digitális ártalmakról
hiszen ott olyan jelenségek vannak
aminek sokszor a gyerekek a nyelvezetét
sem értik ők egészen másfajta
veszélyekben vannak ak már benne tehát
ilyen szempontból én azt gondolom hogy
segíteni kell a közoktatást mindenképpen
és segíteni kell persze a szülőket is
brigitta röviden bemutatkozol te is
kérlek én végzettségemet tekintve
kommunikációs szakember vagyok és
tréner ezen kívül reklámgrafikus é ami
miatt igazából itt ebben a
beszélgetésben úgy érzem helyen van az
hogy 2016-ban indítottam csíkszereda
környékén az akkori munkahelyemmel a
juventuti alapítvánnyal egy online
biztonság z tudatossághoz kapcsolódó
programot és és igazából ez egy ilyen
személyes küldetésemnek tekintett téma
azóta is így találkoztunk csilláikkkal
és kezdtünk hosszabb távon is
együttműködésben én elsősorban
gyerekekkel dolgoztam és már 2016-tól a
mai napig a
programommal iskolákban szülői
közösségekkel ifjúsági közösségekkel
dolgozom szervezetekhez megyek el és a
és a digitális tudatosság különböző
letejét amire épp meghívást kapok abból
készülök föl ti létrehozhatok egy egy
közös képzéssorozatot mesélnétek erről
hogy miről szól ez a képzésorozat és
hogy ha valakit érdekel akkor hogyan
tudja ezt elírni igen ennek a programnak
a kerete az egy erasmus program volt egy
nemzetközi program ott külföldi
szakértőktől is nagyon sok jó anyagot
kaptunk amit mi adaptáltunk a helyi
viszonyokrael felnőtteknek elsősorban
szülőknek tartunk
foglalkozásokat digitális biztonság
digitális család ez szokott lenni a cím
legtöbbször témába illetve az utóbbi
időben kísérletezünk intergenerációs
foglalkozásokkal és ezek a kedvenceink
nem tudom hogy vagy vele brigita de a
most a nagy imr és második az rendkívül
jól sikerült ott nagyon jó nagyon jó
dinamikát egy szülő és egy gyerek mert a
befogadó képességnek határa van teh ez
osztályban nem férnek be többen így is
két felé kell osztani ugye az osztályt
egy szülő és egy gyerek jönnek és olyan
foglalkozásokat vezetünk amiben mi azt
próbáljuk facilitálni támogatni hogy a
gyerekek bátran megnyíljanak tehát ne
titkolják mondjuk a digitális életüket
sőt büszkék legyenek hogy szüleikkel
megoszthatnak ebből bizonyos dolgokat
ugyanakkor elcsöpögtetjük azokat a
biztonsági megfontolásokat is amire a
szülőnek oda kell figyelni és ami talán
a leges legfontosabb hogy teremtünk
másfél órát arra hogy egy szülő egy
gyerek ezen a té mán együtt gondolkodnak
együtt játszanak megmutatják egymásnak a
telefonjaikat közös kvízen vesznek részt
ki tud többet az adott témába és abban
bízunk hogy hogy létrejön egy olyan
kapcsolódás ezen e téma körül is a szülő
és a gyerek között ami aztán tovább él
tehát úgy látjuk hogy nagyon vidáman
nagyon jó kedvel és ugyanakkor hát főleg
a szülők picit elgondolkodva menneke
mennek el erről a foglalkozásról tehát
azt reméljük hogy ez nem egy ilyen h
hirtelen fellángolás hanem valamit
valaminek alapot teremtünk de ezt nem
tudjuk mert még nem mértük igen hát az
én motiváció hogy meghívjalak titeket az
onnan jön hogy én programozóként
dolgoztam az elmúlt 15 évben és az
én tudattalan arroganciám az volt hogy
én én fel vagyok készülve én tudom hogy
mi történik az interneten technológiai
szempontból nem fognak engem becsapni
nem fognak engem átverni voltak
próbálkozások amikor utólag jöttem rá
hogy hogy valójában mennyire közel is
került hozzám a becsapás lehetősége és
de de valahogy megúsztam eddig mindig és
az egyik beszélgetés során jöttem rá
hogy valójában én 37 évesként mennyire
idősnek számítok mennyire leváltam már y
generációként arról a az előttem levő
generációról a z-ről és az alfáról
fogalmam sincs hogy mit csinálnak nem
tiktokot fel se installáltam például a
telefonomra fogalmam se volt hogy hogy
hogy ott az egy külön kozmosz egy
mikrokozmosz ahol a saját trendeket
saját világukat élik én a facebook
generáció vagyok még mindig és és rá
kellett jönnöm arra is amit valójában
megemlítettünk hogy ez nem technológiai
kérdés ez a digitális biztonság úgyhogy
a célja ennek a ma mai beszélgetésnek az
lesz hogy egy átfogó képet kapjunk arról
hogy mit is jelent miért is beszélünk a
digitális biztonságról és hogy mit is
értünk pontosan ez alatt és nem fogunk
tudni belemenni a részletekbe mert
amikor pont brigi a te előadásodat
hallgattam
és és az volt egy ilyen slide amin amin
volt egy
ilyen diagram ahol 24 különböző
területet említettél meg a digitális
biztonságba és pú ez a digitális
intelligenciaábra
igen digitá igen és és mindegyik
mindegyik részéről lehetne beszélni több
órán keresztül úgyhogy úgyhogy próbáljuk
meg a következő másfél órát arra
használni hogy a szerintetek ami a
legfontosabb egy átlagszülőnek és főként
szülőket fogunk most megcélozni de
valójában bármelyik hallgatónak a amit
fontosnak tartotok abban hogy hogy mi az
amiről érdemes lenne beszélni átfogóan
meg megvizsgálni és hogyha valamibe
érdemes akkor belemehetünk részletebben
részletesebben de talán az már egy
következő epizód lesz brigitte hogy hogy
látod hogy melyek azok a nagy területek
amikről amelyekről érdemes beszélgetni
digitális biztonság terén én ebbe a
digitális intelligenciaábrába azért
kapaszkodok bele mert nekem is el
kellett teljen egy jó pár év vagy
tényleg így eleinte én is keresgéltem a
helyemet hogy akkor bemegyek iskolába és
akkor azt gondolják hogy programozó
vagyok vagy valamilyen valamilyen
technikai szakember és hogy hogy
szükségem volt és nagyon-nagyon örültem
mikor ez így összeállt az én fejemen is
hogy hogy milyen sok területe van és
hogy megtalálhattam benne magamat és én
én azért szoktam és azért szerettem meg
ki is szoktuk emelni ezt a ezt a 24
területet vagy a nyolc fő témát mint
például digitális jogok vagy maga a
digitális biztonság digitális
magabiztosság digitális érzelmi
intelligencia
egyensúly kommunikáció mert hogy ez ez
megmutatja mindazt hogyha én mondjuk egy
bizonyos területen nem is vagyok
feltétlen elmélyülve olyan szinten az
nem azt jelenti hogy a 24 szeletből
legalább kettő három másikba ne tudnék
hiteles lenni és és hogy én ma mai napig
ezekbe ezekbe a kulcszavakba
belekapaszkodok mert úgy gondolom hogy
nagyon fontos az is hogy akár a gyerekek
akár a szülők tudjanak bizonyos jogi
jogi kérdésekről bocsánat tehát tudjanak
bizonyos jogi kérdésekről vagy
egyáltalán találkozzanak azzal hogy mit
jelent hogy digitális egyensúly a
képernyőidőfogalma a mi az hogy
digitális lábnyom a az online
kommunikáció miben különbözik mondjuk a
a személyes kommunikáció tehát hogy
annyi téma van amit otthon is hétköznapi
helyzetben lehet alkalmazni hogy hogy
tényleg lehet másfél órába ez ez nem is
tudna mind beleférni szörföljünk akkor
egy kicsit ezekbe a témákba mi lenne az
első téma amit
feldobnátok talán az ezt meg előző
kérdés az hogy egyáltalán miért is
beszélünk erről miért fontos erről
beszélni azt mondja valaki hogy én nem
vagyok jób a telefonommal nem szeretem
ezeket a modern dolgokat én teljesen
párhuzamosan akarom élni az életemet
tőle miért ne tehetném meg és szülőként
miért ne tehetném meg mi lenne erre a
válaszotok nektek szülőként megteheted
akkor hogyha van egy házastársad a
gyerekednek van egy másik szülő szülője
aki viszont ezzel a témával foglalkozik
ezt így meg lehet úszni sehogyan másképp
a ahogy a brigitta is említette a
legtöbb vagy nagyon sok szülő vagy vagy
azon az állásponton van hogy hogy hát ez
nekem magas meg amúgy se tudnám követni
és akkor minek foglalkozni vele vagy
pedig tényleg ilyen kicsit magabiztos
mint te hogy akkor akkor ezzel nem kell
nekünk különösebben foglalkozni a ugye a
gyerekek tőlünk nem technikai tud várnak
vagy nem arra van szükségük hanem
értékrendre van szükségük és biztonságra
van szükségük talán fordított a sorrá
mint ahogy én most soroltam az nagyon
fontos azt hiszem így bevezetőben hogy
minden szülőt megnyugtassunk egyrészről
másrészt elgondolkodtassunk azzal amit a
kutatások is egyértelműen aláhúznak hogy
a gyerekek online biztonságát
meghatározó egyetlen és legfontosabb
tényező az egy szülővel vagy egy egy
megbízható felnőttel való mély és
őszinte kapcsolatuk a a kötődés az hogy
a gyerek van akihez forduljon akár
kérdéssel akár akkor hogyha bajba kerül
egyrészről van akivel megossza akár a
félelmeit akár az élményeit a digitális
világ kapcsán is illetve van valaki és
ez ugyanannyira fontos aki szabályokat
állít aki kereteket állít hogy hogy hogy
ne kódjon el a gyerek ebben a világban
na de át kérdezhetném hogy milyen rossz
dolog történhet az interneten milyen
veszélyek leselkednek mondhat hogy
veszélyekkel találkozhat a úgyhogy én
még egy picit kapcsolódhatok
kapcsolódnék az előzőhöz azzal hogy még
kiegészítve hogyha egy szülő foglalkozik
ezzel a témával bármilyen motiváció is
legyen vagy azért mert hallotta egy
podcastb hogy kell ezzel foglalkozni
vagy mert hogy ez így ez így jön és érzi
hogy ennek felelős felelőssége van
igazából már azzal hogy érdek lődik vagy
a gyerek látja tapasztalja hogy ez
otthon tematizálva van tehát ez bejön a
hétköznapi kommunikációbaan nyelvezetben
már azzal is egy olyan alapot teremt
amibe a gyerek könnyebben kapaszkodik
hogy én például az iskolákban ezt
tapasztalom hogy nagyon gyakran azzal
hogy látják hogy foglalkoztat a téma
kérdezem őket érdekel ez a világ nem
zárom ki nem utasítom teljesen vissza
már azzal annyira nyílt dolgokkal hozzám
mernek fordulni egy foglalkozás végén
hogy hogy meglepő és hogy tényleg nagyon
jó alapokat lehet teremteni tehát
valójában ezek a fiatalok is keresnek és
válaszokat keresnek megpróbálják
érzelmileg megemészteni azt amit amit
amit látnak ott és és
igazából nekünk elég hogyha nyitottak
vagyunk azt mondjátok és és ők majd
keresni fognak minket hát bízunk benne
hogy nem egyértelmetlen dolog nyitottnak
lenni illetve észrevesszük hogyha valami
nem oké még akkor is hogyha nem keres
bennünket
de hogy föl kell föl kell igen föl kell
készülni azért néhány dolog ra mondtad
hogy mi rossz tehát hogy ne ússzuk meg a
kérdést hogy mi rossz történhet a a
gyerekeinkkel el lehetne kezdeni egy
ilyen hosszú sorol felsorolást amiben
így halálra ijezgetjük a szülőket hogy
mi minden történhet a gyerekekkel és
ezek mind reális dolgok ugyanakkor én
azt gondolom hogy csak egy vékony
rétegét érintik a gyerekeknek és talán a
legtöbb szülő nem ezzel ezzel szembesül
még akkor akkor is hogyha mit tudom
szenzációs dolgokra lehetne itt
számítani nézettséget tekintve vagy nem
tudom mi tehát például a ínédzserek
között eléggé nagy arányban van például
pornófüggő ami egyértelműen ugye az
internetről származó pornót jelenti de
nem nem ezek a nagyon jellemző dolgok
hanem hanem érdemes ilyenkor megnézni
ugye nagyon nehéz mert a kutatás mindig
egy kicsit kullog a
technológiai sebesség mögött olyan új
jelenségek vannak amik amik
világtrendeket ok znak és millió
gyereket vagy gyerekek millióit érintik
világszinten és ezek két három hét alatt
akár fejtik ki a hatásukat és ehhez
képest egy egy longitudinális hosszú
kutatás az nem tudja ezeket csak utólag
bemérni hogy mi volt ennek igen mi volt
ennek a hatása de azért érdemes egy
kicsit figyelni arra hogy mit mondanak a
kutatók és van egy ilyen szintén sokkoló
eléggé eltájá sokat vitatott de
legtöbbek által a helyesség elismert
kutatás amerikából 2021-es kutatás
amikor igazából nem is az online világot
kezdték kutatni hanem visszanéztek
olyan olyan korábbi kutatásokat
amelyekben a tudósok az amerikai
egyetemeken levő fiatalok mentális
állapotát vizsgálták tehát milyen
mentális veszélyeknek vannak kitéve
milyen a általános mentális állapotuk
menny hajlamosak öngyilkosságra satöbbi
és akkor még amikor ez a kutatás folyt a
a 2000-es évek elején elején vagy
2010-es években is akkor akkor még nem
gondoltak arra hogy itt az online
világnak a hatása vagy nem tudom mi
vizsgálandó lenne de most amikor
visszanézik a kutatásokat akkor azt
látják hogy a az egyetemistaorúak és nem
sokra rá a huszonévesek körében rettentő
nagy arányban kiugrik a mentális
problémáknak a a a száma az
öngyilkossággal kapcsolatos kísérletek
gondolatok
satöbbi kísérletek száma és akkor
egyszer csak összenézték ezt azokkal a
az eseményekkel amelyek a kezdetben a
facebook egyetemi körökben való
elterjedését majd az instagram
megjelenését és felfutását mutatják és
egyértelmű korrelációnó mutatható ki
tehát a közösségi média amely ugye a
lehető legcinikusabb
önmegnevezéssel nevezi magát
közösséginek az az az nagyon izolál
nagyon nagy lelki problémákat okoz
összehasonlítgatásokba hajszolja az
embereket énképzavarokat okoz
alvásmegvonást okoz és akkor csak néhány
dolgot említettünk tehát
már ebből a kutatásból is egyértelműen
jól látszik hogy nem lehet ennek a ennek
a szerepét szerepé hanyagolni és ugye
akkor ha szétnézünk a környezetünkben
akkor
óhatatlanul is látunk sajnos olyan
szomorú vagy éppen tragikus eseteket
amikor az internetnek köze volt ahhoz
ami legszörnyűbb dolog egy gyerekkel
történt milyen közösségi médiákat
használnak most a a fiatalok melyek a
legnépszerűbb közösségi médiapatformok
hát egyértelműen én általában a
foglalkozásokra viszek egy olyan diát
amin 13 ilyen logó szoktam kivetíteni
nekik amit én így látok hogy az
instagram a chates alkalmazások közül
ugye messenger whatsapp kisebb
osztályokba de már a snapchat is bejön
akár egy négyes egy nég-eseknél is
találkoztam ezzel hogy használják akkor
közg mondom a telegram
annyira nem annyira nem tapasztaltam de
lehet hogyha elviszem azt a logót is
akkor kiderül több ugye a youtube tiktok
ezek amiket
felismernek discord twitch
ugye az élő adások közvetítéséről szóló
platform
pinterest kis kicsit ártalmatlanabbnak
tűnők közül
illetve nagyjából nagyjából most ezek
jutnak eszembe ami ami fontos igazából
hogy szülő szülői szemmel nézve hogy
azért érdemes megismerni ezeket a
platformokat vagy például a b jut most
eszembe nem elsősorban azért hogy aztán
a szülő letöltse és kipróbálja vagy
ilyesmi de hogy mondjuk a youtube-on án
nézhet hogy miről szól egy ilyen felület
megnézheti különböző oldalakon hogy hány
éves kortól ajánlják más szülők satöbbi
ez ez egy irányadó lehet illetve hogy a
működéséből adódóan bizonyos témák fel
tudnak merülni egy-egy applikáció
kapcsán most ha így szülői szemmel nézem
akkor én nem azt javasolnám hogy
föltétlen töltse le és akkor úgy
próbálja ki de hogyha kíváncsi akkor
akár ez is egy megoldás hanem nézzen
utána például youtube youtube-on egy-egy
bemutató videóban hogy miről szól mert
vannak alkalm ások ahol eltűnhetnek
üzenetek ugye és akkor itt bejön egy
nagyon fontos beszélgetési téma otthonra
hogy mi ennek a kockázata vagy vannak
alkalmazások amelyek a nap bármely
pillanatában értesítést köldenek mondjuk
a bíril ugye hogy akkor itt az ideje
hogy a most posztto és akkor érdemes
kitérni hogy hogy mik ezek a a marketing
trükkök vagy mik ezek a kis
horgok amivel megpróbálják megpróbálják
napi szintű felhasználóvá tenni a a
gyerekek h valójában ezek a platformok
iszonyatos mennyiségű pénzt fektetnek
abba hogy kutassák az emberi
agyműködését hogy honnan kap
dopaminforrást például hogy hogyan lehet
a legizgalmasabbá legaddiktívabbá tenni
magát a platformot ilyen például a a
facebook vagy a a a tiktok és és
miközben használja a fiatal fogalma
sincs arról hogy valójában egy
kutatási kísérleti egés kísérleti egér
pontosan viszont ők ezt a témát amúgy ez
érdekli őket tehát én az iskolában azt
tapasztalom hogy mondjuk ötödikesekkel
már már nagyon jól el tudunk erről
beszélgetni hogy hogy akkor mivel érik
el ezek a platformok hogy te minden nap
akard használni és és érdemes beleállni
a gyerekekkel ilyen beszélgetésekbe nem
kell nem biztos hogy nagy szakértő kell
legyek egy-két cikket mondjuk elolvasok
a témába hogy legyenek meg rá a
megfelelő szavaim azt megpróbálom a
gyerekem korosztályához igazítva
alkalmazni de hogy hogy nyugodtan lehet
ezekről beszélgetni akár a reklámokról
vagy vagy hogyan szereznek pénzt ezek a
a ek hogy jutnak és pontosan talán ez a
legjobb legjobb mérőszám hogy valahol
egy profit profitorientált vállalkozás
fen kell maradjon fenn kell maradjon
tehát hogy hogy lehetséges hogy ez a sok
minden ingyenes nem nincs valami gyanú
bennünk hogy itt van egy több milliárd
dolláros üzlet ami profitábilisan
működik és én ingyen használom valójában
én vagyok a termék az én figyelmem a
termék í van és vannak szülők akik
beszélnek erről mert hogy sőt az utóbbi
időben tapasztalok egyre több ilyen az
utóbbi években vannak ilyen
tapasztalataim hogy hogy elmondják a
gyerekek hogy igen apukámmal otthon
beszéltünk róla és ő szokta mondani hogy
ami ingyenes ott ott én én vagyok az én
időm az amivel fizetek igen hát az hogy
mit használnak a gyerekek azt legjobban
úgy tudhatjuk meg hogyha megkérdezzük a
gyerekeinket csak ugye kérdezni jó kell
tudni jól jól kell tudni kérdezni hogy
kell ezt megkérdezni hát te most például
ahogy kérdezted hogy hogy lehet az hogy
egy
egy profitábilis egy biznisz hogyha
minden ingyenes benne ez például egy
nagyon jó kérdés amit amit a gyerekeknek
föl kell tenni őszinte érdeklődéssel
vagy hogyha hullafáradtak vagyunk péntek
délután 4y00-kor akkor legalább az
őszinte az őszinteséget míelve de hogy
oda kell menni és meg kell kérdezni a
gyereket hogy hogy mi újság mikkel
foglalkozol miket látsz mostanában
mondjuk lehet ez túl általános de
belekapaszkodhatunk egy hírbe amit a
médiában láttunk hogy képzeld el hogy én
azt olvastam hogy a tiktokon ez és ez
történt te hallottál ilyet nagyon
gyakran ugye a gyerekek nem szívesen
beszélnek a személyes érintettségükről
de hogyha van egy barátom akinek volt
egy barátja akivel történt valami akkor
onnan nagyon-nagyon jól ki lehet indulni
illetve a másik ilyen módszer lehet az
hogyha a szülő őszinte és azt mondja
hogy juj képzeld el a tegnap leültem
facebookozni és azt hittem hogy öt perc
és odaégett a leves vagy nem tudom tehát
hogy most nyilván parodizálok egy kicsit
de hogyha ilyen önreflexív őszinte módon
azt mondjuk hogy hú van neked valami
ötleted hogy én akkor ezt hogy csináljam
következőbe vagy hogyha elfogadjuk a
gyerektől a kritikát hogyha hogyha azt
mondja hogy tedd már le anya a telefont
vagy tedd már le apa a telefont akkor
akkor egy kicsit leülünk és nem azt
mondjuk hogy ó fiam dolgom van nem tudom
fogd be a szád hanem hanem azt mondjuk
hogy te tényleg egy kicsit sokat van
nálam a telefon én is nagyon szeretném
hogy másképp legyen lesz egy hétvégénk
amikor apa nem válaszol a telefonra de
most itt van ez a projekt ezt be kell
fejezném
azt hiszem hogy a kérdés az mindig olyan
legyen hogy hogy nem felkérdező nem
számonkérő nem elítélő és akkor a a a
még az is nagyon fontos hogy a mikor a
kérdésre valami meglepő választ kapunk
vagy olyat amit nem szeretnénk hallani
akkor akkor arra hogy reagálunk hogy
becsapjuk-e az összes kommunikációs
ajtót azzal hogy leordítjuk a gyerek
fejét kioktatjuk hogy jó kisfiam milyen
hülye vagy bedőltél ennek a nem tudom
minek vagy vagy egy kicsit ha jobb
ötletünk nincs akkor hümmögünk egy 10-et
15-öt és akkor azalatt van időnk egy
kicsit átfogalmazni a dolgokat és akár
kérdésként föltenni az ami nekünk nem
tetszik hogy mit gondolsz hogy ez hogy
hatott a másikra vagy hogy érintette azt
aki megkapta azt az üzenetet
vagy próbáljunk a megértés felé haladni
az lázat útján mint hogy mi se tudjuk a
válasá pontosan ezek a
kérdésmegfogalmazások vagy bocsánat
ahogy csilla feltette ezek konkrétan
nyitott kérdéseknek hívjuk vagyis hogy
hogy lehetőség van
mesélni vagy valami történetet
hozzáfűzni tehát hogy még amit lehet
esetleg a kérdésfeltevésnél meg
megpróbálni elkerülni hogy miért vagy
miért nem tehát hogy valahogy ne ne így
kezdődjön hanem hogy mi a véleményed mit
gondolsz ez pontosan ahogy ahogy
elhangzott igen én majd szeretnék több
területre is rákérdezni a közösségi
média az csak az egyik amiről
végtelenségig lehet beszélgetni de talán
az az egyik alapelv ami ami összeköti az
összes területet hogy maga ez a fajta
nyitottság ez a a nyitott kérdező szülő
aki aki tanulni akar és hozza az
alapelveket ami az életében megtanult
alapelveket és azt akarja hogy együtt
ezekkel az alapelvekkel közösen a a
gyermekével találják meg azt az utat ami
élhető mindenki számára ez egy veszélyes
dolog mert valójában ez visszahat a
szülőre is mert a a a a szülő digitális
eszköz használatára is visszahat hogy
valójában hány órakor tesszük le a
telefont közösen vagy hogy mikor válas
unk egy emmailre vagy mikor veszem fel a
telefont hol tartjuk a telefont éjszaka
hol tartjuk a telefont éjszaka hány
órakor kapcsoljuk ki magát a képernyőt
szóval ezek a kérdések olyan dolgok
amelyek amelyek veszélyesek a szülőkreé
és valójában én azt látom itt hogy
amiatt is egy teljesen új terület hogy
ez az egész információrobbanás ez a
digitális robbanás mindenkit váratlanul
ért minden generációt egyszerre tehát
nem az van hogy van egy veterán
generáció akinek már megvannak a
régbejáratot válaszai hanem ugyanúgy a a
10 éves kislányt váratlanul éri mint a
80 éves nagymamát a szóval a még egy egy
egy pillanatra visszamennék még a
közösségi médiához hogy melyek azok az
alap
alapveszélyforrások amit láttok úgy
minden egyes közösségi médiában úgy
mintaként megismétlődni például egy
egyet mondok egy példát és lássam hogy
egyetértetek-e vele és akkor még
boncolgathatjuk számomra az egyik
legveszélyesebb dolog az hogy a
közösségi média megenged egy olyan
dolgot amit soha világtörténelemben nem
engedett meg még pedig az hogy anonimok
maradjunk tehát az az előző
közösségekben egy faluan vagy egy
városban mindig a nevünket az arcunkat
vállalnunk kellett tehát nem
kommentelhettünk egy olyat amiután
hogyha most látok egy-egy olyan
kommentet hogy ha azt élőben történne
meg akkor körülbelül fél másodperc alatt
kapna egy pofot érte de az hogy anonimok
maradjunk ez valami természetellenes
sosem voltunk anonimok és és most
először a a a úgy tudunk kialakítani egy
olyan képet magunkról ami elfedi a
valódi identitásunkat egy hamis képet
mutat hamis
identitással és akár több párhuzamos
ilyen identitásunk lehet amivel több
párhuzamos világot tudunk
élni egyszerre és több párhuzamos
mikroközösséghez tudunk tartozni ez is
egy furcsa dolog mert ilyen nem volt
előtte hogy például a laposföldhívők az
egyik legfurcsább kategória számomra
hogy azelőtt a falu bolondjának hívták
ezt a személyt és egy volt belő őle a
faluban és mindenki tudta hogy ő a a
paprikás jóska de de most az összes
falubolondja amt hogyha egy nagy
közösséget tudna alkotni és ilyen furcsa
képződmények történnek mint például a
lapos földhívőknek a a klubja ahol az
emberek nyíltan tudományos pontosabban
áltudományos bizonyítékokat hoznak hogy
a föld valójában miérlapos vagy a
kenyérszeletet a fához kapszálló redit
csoport annak is nagyon sok erő semmit
nem tudok ez ez ez megér egy percet
meséld nekem ez micsoda tehát ugye a
redit az az egy az egy a sok közösségi
háló közül aminek vannak nagyon tehát
inkább így érdeklődési kör mentén
szerveződnek az emberek ezen a csoporton
és vannak nagyon hasznos tehát ez a ezt
mindig el kell mondani ugye mielőtt a
mielőtt a gyereket minden egyes
közösségi hálóról letiltanánk hogy hogy
alap ott alapvetően jó dolgok is
megvannak ugye ahogy ez a műsor is a
közösségi médián fog menni de hogy a mi
felelősségünk hogy szelektáljunk a
hülyeség és a és a és a jó dolgok között
az egy másik kérdés hogy olyan nagyon
nagyon nagyon sokat kell szelektálnunk a
hülyeség és a jó dolgok között hogy az
agyunknak ezt most már tényleg tudósok
mutatták ki hogy az agyunknak az illető
agyterületet borzasztóan igénybe vesszük
és egyszerűen egy idő után elfárad és
már nehezudun
igen de hogy visszatérve igen a redit a
rediten kialakulnak nem csak értelmes
mit tudom szakmai csoportok vagy szakmai
érdeklődés mentén szervező csoportok
hanem ilyen teljesen nonszens nonszens
csoportok és ott a az egyik ilyen
csoport a ez akik kenyérszeleteket fához
kapszálnak és és a nagy viták folynak a
csoporton belül arról hogy jól
kapszálta-e oda és ki kell tiltani a
csoportból vagy nem kell kitiltaniia mi
az értelme ennek semmilyen értelme
nincsen tehát ez az egyike azoknak a
közösségi média jelenségeknek amit
valószínűleg a az unalom meg ez a
csoporthoz tartozás szükségesség váreg
pillanatra tehát hogyha ha ha azt
mondják hogy jól kapsz áltad oda azt
jelenti van egy ideál tehát lehet jól
odakap ni persze vannak tutorialok hogy
hogy kell ezt de hogyog de hogy az aki
nagyon jól csinálja az az nem tárja fel
a titkát hogy miért csinálja ezt az
egészet de de mindig vannak újítók nem
tudom érdemes erre erre több szót
veszégetni j tát gyanítom akkor ehhez
hasonló őrült furcsa csoportok
létrejönnek é igen de nem csak a
csoportokra érdemes odafigyelni hanem az
influencerekre is ilyen szelektálási
szempontból mert hogy hogy ugye ezért is
érdemes hogy tényleg információkat
gyűjtsön egy szülő is arról hogy kik
ezek az influencerek miről is van
pontosan szó szó kiket követ konkrétan a
az ő gyereke mert hogy hogy közöttük is
vannak akik nagyon gyakran ilyen
szélsőségesebb tanokat hoznak be vagy
olyan elveket képviselnek amivel
valószínű hogyha egy szülő egy fél adást
vagy egy videót vagy egy közvetítést
végighallgat az adott influencerrel
akkor máris lesz egy jó beszélgetési
téma mert valamit fog találni amivel nem
ért egyet vagy lehet hogy épp kiderül
hogyha belehallgat hogy egy nagyon
hasznos és tudományos alapokra helyezett
érdekes információkat átadó influencert
követ a gyerek de it van másik veszély
ami sosem volt gyakorlatilag a
történelemben hogy a kompetencia és a a
hírnév úgymond szétvált egymástól tehát
azt a képzetet adják ezek az
influencerek amúgy nem gondolom ezt mer
mindjárt elmondom azt a képzetet adják
hogy igazi belefektetett energia nélkül
valaki lehet sikeres és gazdag és amúgy
én azt gondolom hogy véletlenszerűen nem
lesz valaki hír hírneves tehát hogy ezek
az influencerek keményen dolgoznak a
háttérbe egy stáb van mögöttük akik
folyamatosan forgatják ezeket nem
egyedül csinálják lehet hogy van egy
szerencsés egy-két videó de a szerencse
keveset számít én most már
tapasztalatból látom hogy valaki nem
lesz csak úgy véletlenszerűen sikeres a
a youtube-on például viszont azt az
érzetet adják a fiataloknak hogy ez egy
könnyű megélhetési forma egyszerűen csak
videókat kell feltöltsek magamról és
bohóckodjak és olyan dolgokat csináljak
ami egyre vadabb és egyre kirívóbb a
környezetembe ami megint egy egy
teljesen hamis és nem reális kép a a a
amit egy fiatal kap a világról abszolút
és amúgy kölő ikó filmrendezővel volt
egy ilyen beszélgetésünk ugye csak ebben
a projektben ahol ő nagyon-nagyon
hasznos tippeket adott ilyen szempontból
szülőknek úgyhogy igazából abból tudok
esetleg egy kicsit meríteni mert ő azt
mondja hogy ezért érdemes mondjuk egy
olyan gyereknek megmutatni hogy miről is
szól valójában mondjuk egy
forgatás aki érdeklődik az
influencerkedés iránt mert amikor
meglátja egy gyerek mondjuk tényleg
szakmai közekben beíratjuk egy ilyen
táborba ami gyerekeknek szól satöbbi
mert hogy lehet ilyen jellegű
programokat találni amikor a gyerek
szembesül vele hogy ez egy mekkora
türelemmel és mekkora precizitással meg
fegyelemmel járó tevékenység akkor lehet
hogy két-három héten belül le is unja
ezt az ötletét hogy ő influencer lesz
tehát hogy amúgy erre is jó hogyha a
szülő felkészül az influencerek kapcsán
hogy lehet egyszer felmerül a gyerekben
hogy hogy őt ez érdekli és pont ildiko
mondta ezt a példát hogy amikor a gyerek
mondjuk festő akar lenni akkor akor
akkor nem akkor nem egyből neki egy nagy
kiállítást szervezünk tehát veszünk neki
egy galériát hanem először papírt
ceruzát vagy ecsetet kap és gyakorolja
és valahogy így kell ezt a dolgot is
elképzelni hogyha a gyereknek tényleg
van arra affinitása hogy ő ilyen irányba
elmenjen és érdekli a a a digitális
tartalom előállítás akkor lehet hogy
kell adni neki eszközöket kipróbálhassa
megtapasztalhassa és hogy tényleg
szervezett és felügyelt közegben
kipróbálhassa e a médiaműhelynek is ez a
missziója hogy legyen egy kontrollált
környezet ahol az emberek kipróbálhatják
a de már gyakorlatilag azt is mondod
hogy már előtte otthon amatőr
eszközökkel el lehet kezdeni sőt érdemes
elkezdeni hát akárhogy otthon a
családnak gyárt először együtt ez ez
nagyon tetszik ez nem az én gondolatom
egyébként hanem tényleg ebből az
interjúból ez egy komoly családi meg
igen társadalmi feladat is akár a
tműhelyetek is ebbe nagyon jól be tud
kapcsolódni itt rengeteg lehetőség van
most az iskola másként meg hasonló
hasonló programokkal hogy hogy ebben
részt vegyetek hogy hogy igen a mi
felelősségünk megmutatni azt hogy a
siker mögött mekkora erőfeszítés van és
lehet hogy ez a nagyon hirtelennek tűnő
és influencer jellegű népszerűség ez egy
társadalmilag ú jelenség de korábban is
ha belegondolsz a sztárok vagy a
nagyportolókról általában csak akkor
hallottunk amikor megnyerte az olimpiát
amikor jöttek a fényes érmek és ugye
mögötte ott van ez amit sikergörbének
neveznek am ami a sikergörbének a nagyon
utolsó 10%-a ilyen felszállóág a előtte
meg ott van egy hosszú lapos meg sokszor
lefelé
menő egyenes vagy nem egyenes hanem
hullámos vonal és arról ugyanúgy keveset
tudtunk régen mint amennyire keveset
tudunk most arról hogy a egy
influenzernek mi van a sikere mögött jó
a nagyon egyetértek ezekkel és nagyon
tetszett is ez a példa még egy dolgot
amit így megemlítenék és ez egy ilyen
gondolat a fejemben lássuk hogy ha
elmondom mi a véleményetek róla hogy a
harmadik dolog amit így meg tudnék
említeni a közösségi médiánál hogy
hogy furcsa irányba ment el és magamon
is észre kell egy évvel ezelőtt
körülbelül realizáltam mielőtt még a
podcastem elindult volna hogy én
valójában nem veszek részt aktívan hanem
passzívan veszek részt a közösségi
médiában ugyancsak egy arrogancia volt a
mögötte hogy én vagyok az a bölcs
csendes valaki aki megvizsgálom a
dolgokat és megvan a saját véleményem de
nem mondom el mert nem fogok én oda
leereszkedni hogy kommenteljek és nem
fogok a mondjam úgy hogy a a a disznók
közé vegyülni és rájöttem arra hogy ez
helytelen ez a hozzáállásom mégpedig az
hogy ha ha én nem teszem ezt és a hozzám
hasonló bölcs emberek akik távolról
próbálják vizsgálni a dolgokat nem
teszik akkor maradnak azok ott akik akik
nem riadnak ettől vissza tehát a
nárcizmust a szociopátiát és a
pszichopátiát felerősíti ez a közösségi
média mert azok az emberek fognak
influencerek lenni akik akiket nem zavar
hogyha negatív kritika éri őket sőt
talán még
mint például a nárcisztikusokat is
energizálja még a negatív figyelem is
őket és egyre torzabb és egyre egyre
keményebb képet fognak alkotni tehát
látszik a például a az influencerek
között az instagramon egy-egy olyan
torzult modell torz képét látjuk aki jól
néz ki azon a képen de nem élet nem
életszerű és például én nem szeretném a
lányomat ott látni és nyilván nem tudom
hogy csak csak úgy tudom megvédeni ahogy
te is mondtad hogy nyitottan kérdezek és
elmondom az én világképemet és két
világkép valójában az instagram
világképe és az én világképem összecsap
és amelyik hitelesebb az fog nyerni de
más módot nem látok én arra hogy
megvédjem a lányomat hogy ne tegye ki
magát az instagramra mint egy árucik
hogy kommenteljék és
vizsgálgassák szóval hogy visszatérve az
alapgondolatomhoz hogy a közösségi média
felerősíti a nárcizmust felerősíti a
szociopátiát a pszichopátiát és és
valójában erre az ellenszer az egyetlen
ellenszer amit kaptam az az hogy
egyrészt a családok erősen a
háttérben informálják és és valójában ez
a háború amit mondtam hogy egy ilyen
spirituális háború amiatt történik
történhet egy családban a másik pedig az
hogy a közösségi médiába felszólalok
elmondom a véleményemet és valójában
azáltal hogy egy alternatív világképet
is lehet kapni úgymond a a a el lehet
érni az interneten nem csak ezeket a
torzakat valójában már ott is
megtörténik ez a háb ü mi a véleményetek
erről a gondolatról én nekem az a
gondolat jutott eszembe hogy hiszek
abban hogy mindenki meg kell találja azt
a területet amit ő hitelesen tud
képviselni lehet van valaki aki aki
mondjuk a facebookon nyilvános
megszólalásaiban bejegyzéseiben lehet
valaki videóban kommunikál ezekről a
dolgokról vagy egy kicsit ellensúlyozza
ezeket a akár szélsőséges irányb ható
pólusokat lehet hogy lesz valaki aki
mondjuk foglalkozásokat tart iskolában
vagy előadást vagy egy szülő is ő is meg
kell találja hogy mi mit tud hitelesen
képviselni hogy lehet hogy az nem lesz
segítségére ha ahogy említettem letölti
a tiktokot de az hogyha hogyha tényleg
találkozik egy olyan kommenttel még
hogyha szóban is legalább ezt felhozza
otthon beszélgetésnek az is egyfajta
képviselete ennek az ellenpólusnak
viszont hogyha nem veszünk részt ebbe a
kommunikációba olyan minth hogyha nem
mennénk el szavazni mintogyha úgy
protestálnánk azt mondjuk én nem megyek
el mert nincs is értelme az szavazásnak
de valójában a döntés így is úgy is meg
fog születni egy választás során még
akkor is hogyha nem megyek el a
felnőttekre valószínűleg igaznak tartom
ezt amit mondasz vagy legalábbis azok az
emberek akik képesnek érzik magukat hogy
szembem menjenek az árral azokat
biztatom hogy mint te is hogy te
tegyétek ezt meg
a ugyanakkor ugye létezik a másik is a a
másik pólus amikor úgy érezzük és ez a
passzív használatra vonatkozik amikor
úgy érezzük hogy túl sok ugye volt ez a
az a fomo a fear of missing out hogy
félek attól hogy kimaradok valamitől és
ma már van egy másik terminus ennek az
ellentéte a jomo a joy of missing out
amikor örülök annak hogy valamiből
kimaradok hogy hogy a a gyerekek
többsége nagy többsége az ideje nagy
többségében passzív fogyasztó tehát ez
amit te is mondtál amikor gondolom lesz
itt még képernyőidőről szó de amikor a a
képernyőidő értékéről beszélünk akkor
azért azt szoktuk mondani hogy hogy a
passzív fogyasztás az mindig egy
alacsonyabb rendű képernyőidő mint az
aktív a kreatív képernyőhasználat tehát
amikor én készítek valami tartalmat
persze aztán a kreatívon belül vannak az
extrémek amikor hülyeségeket produkálok
de nem arról van szó hiszen a
gyermekeink többsége
gondolom hogy ki is próbál hülyeségeket
igen kipróbál de hogy ezt ezt csak ezt
csak rövidebb időre és ha van egy biztos
értékrend bázis körülötte meg van egy
szabályrendszer akkor az csak úgy
gyorsan a kezét odateszi a forró
tűzhelyhez és aztán elkapja de hogy a
gyerekek többsége azért próbál kreatívan
jó dolgokat művelni vagy föltenni vagy
exponálni igen ezt ez sokkal inkább
értelmes dolog mint a passzív fogyasztás
a közösségi médiának a legtöbb káros
eleme az a passzív fogyasztásból van a
ugye az addikció amiről beszéltünk hogy
függővé tesz ez a dopaminszerotonin
játék amit a mi agyunkkal
játszanak tudományos alapokon amúgy de
hogy de hogy emellett ott van a
társadalmi hasonlítgatás ami egy ilyen
nagyon nagyon nag negatív dolog a ennek
ezt ezt mondjuk laboratóriumi
körülmények között is kipróbálták
bizonyították hogy
ő két fele osztottak egy azonos
társadalmi státuszú csoportot az egyik
csoportnak azt a feladatot adták hogy ti
beszéljetek a ti városotok legszegényebb
embereiről hogy kicsit beszéljétek meg
hogy mik a gondjaik hol élnek mik a
perspektíváik mi van az ő gyerekeikkel
satöbbi és a másik csoportnak meg azt a
feladatot adtál hogy beszéljetek a
városotok leggazdagabb embereiről hogy
ők hol laknak hogy milyen miket engednek
meg maguknak hol tanulnak a gyerekeik
miven járnak satöbbi és akkor utána
adtak egy ilyen társadalmi létrát
mindkét csoportnak hogy jelőljék be
magukat hogy a gazdagtól a szegényik hol
vannak hát ugye nem árulok zsákba
macskát hogyha azok az emberek akik a
szegényekről beszéltek korábban azok
sokkal magasabbra tették magukat a
társadalmi létrán mint az azonos
státuszú emberek akik viszont az a
gazdagokhoz hasonlítgatták magukat na
most a közösségi médián az történik hogy
mi mi folyamatosan a gazdagokhoz has
vagy a gyerekek a gazdagokhoz a
szépekhez akiknek minden klappol akiknek
minden jól megy és hogy ezt is
tudatosítani vagy hogy erről beszélni a
gyerekekkel hogy senki nem rakja ki a
nyomorát vagy extrém esetektől
eltekintve a közösségi médiára tehát
hogy tudatosan visszafogni magunkat hogy
az amit ott látok az nem az emberek
mindennapi realitása és az én életem nem
kevésbé értékes azért mert én nem
nyaralok a baha kon mert lehet hogy a
család aki a bahamákon nyaralz közben
halálosan összevesz vagy nem tudom mi
lesz vele megeszi a cápa most
hülyéskedek de hogy de hogy nem eszi meg
persze a cápa de hogy de hogy az emberi
értékek nem azok amik kifele vannak
hanem amik belül vannak és a családok
nem attól értékesek hogy milyen márkájú
ruha van rajtuk ami így papolásnak tűnik
persze de egyedi esetekben erről egy
kicsit beszélni hogy hogy gondold meg
hogy mikor nagymamánál ülünk az asztal
körül azt mi tudná pótolni am mi
életünkben annak az érzését de akkor
megint ugye visszadobtuk a labdát a a
szülők erítésén mondhatja a szülő hogy
hogy hogy akkor hogy lehet ennyi időt
tölteni a gyerekkel de az a az a helyzet
hogy a gyerekeink azoknak az
értékrendjét fogják magukra venni
akikkel a legtöbb időt töltenek és ez
10-12 éves korig egyértelműen így van ha
a nagymamánál van a legtöbb időt akkor a
nagymama értékrendjét fogja magába
szívni észrevétlenül is ha anyukával van
több időt akkor anyukára fog inkább
az anyuka értékeit fogja vagy az apukáit
vagy hogyha ez egyensúlyban van akkor az
milyen ideális hogyha hogyha a tévét
nézi az amerikai sorozatokat akkor azt
az értékrendet fogja magára venni ma már
kevésbé nézik a gyerekek ha online van
akkor ott és ugye itt akkor feltétlen jó
tudni hogy a gyerek melyik online
buborékban van mert az online az sokféle
lehet akkor onnan fogja az értékrendjét
magára venni tehát hogy ezt a gyerekkel
töltött időt gyerekkel való beszélgetést
ezt sehogy se tudjuk meg viszont a jó
hír az hogy a gyerekeket nagyon érdekli
az online világ és keresve se tudunk
találni olyan témát amiről ők
szívesebben é többet akarnánok beszélni
ha tetszik ez az epizód akkor kérlek ne
felejtsetek el feliratkozni a
csatornánkra osszátok meg valamint
hagyjatok egy kommentet ezzel nagyban
segítitek a munkánkat igen hát így ahogy
meséltél erről el is nehezedett a szívem
egy kicsit mert egyből arra gondoltam
hogy én hogyan használom az eszközöket
otthon és hogy én milyen társadalmi
közeget biztosítok a gyermekeimnek
milyen példát mutatok és hogy mennyi
olyan időt töltök velük amelyek amelyre
büszke vagyok most egy kicsit akkor a
közösségi médiát rakjuk félre annyi más
izgalmas dolog van amiről beszéljünk még
beszéljünk egy kicsit magáról a
képernyőidőről az eszközhasználatról egy
családon belüli
dinamikáról nekem egy négy hét és nyolc
éves gyermekem van haragszanak rám hogy
túl sokat telefonozok
és így menedzserként és programozóként
valójában tényleg az van hogy hogy az
online világ befolyik a személyes
életemben olyankor jönnek meg a a a
válaszok az emailek és egyszerre 10
csatornán olyan üzenetek amiket
pillanatok alatt el tudok intézni és ez
azt az érzetet is adja hogy csak még ezt
megcsinálom csak még azt megcsinálom és
ezért is nehezedett el a szívem mer
hogyha őszinte vagyok magamhoz akkor
talán ez a következő fejlődési szintem
amit amit meg kell valahogy ugorjak ha
nem akarom elveszteni a gyermek ez a jó
hozzáállás és a gyerekeknek is ez a
hiteles mer a gyerekeknek is sokszor
lesz az életükben olyan h most még nincs
olyan dolog hogy túl használunk valamit
rosszul használunk valamit nem jól
osztjuk be az időnket és hogyha egy
szülő ezzel önrelexív tud lenni hát
ennél nagyobb reveláció egy gyereknek
nincs meg ennél nagyobb tartalék az
életében hogy amikor egyszer már túl
sokat néztem nem tudom mit akkor eszembe
jut hogy jaj hát apa is így volt
valamivel de hogy apa erről nekünk
beszélt és hogy megpróbált valamit tenni
és volt egy képernyőmentes szombatunk
vagy nem tudom és akkor az milyen vagány
volt vagy volt egy hely a itt apró
dolgok is elég sok hogy legyen egy hely
a lakásban mondjuk az asztal mellett nem
tudom én én mind abban bízom vagy abban
reménykedem hogy erdélyben még a a
családi ebédek azok még képernyőmentesek
nem biztos így van de hogy ezt azért meg
kell tartani tehát hogy a családi asztal
mellett ne legyen amikor beszélgetünk ne
vegyük elő a telefont kapcsoljuk ki a
tévét sok apukának amúgy ez a kihívás
hogy nem mehet a háttérbe a híradó vagy
nem tudom micsoda
hogy hogy ugye a a egyre több
gyerekorvos azt ajánlja és mindjárt
akkor brigitta kicsit a képernyőidőről
is beszélünk vagy beszélsz ugye
hogy legtöbb gyerekorvos most már mit
tudom amerikában foglalkoznak ezzel
rendszerszinten de szerintem itt is
megerősítik a gyermekorvosok azt ajánlja
hogy a hálószobájában a gyereknek
semmiképp ne legyen bent semmilyen
technikai eszköz éjszaka olyan amit a
szülő
felügyelete nélkül bekapcsolhat és akkor
itt ne áltassuk magunkat a technikai
felügyeleti eszközökkel mert azt már egy
hat éves gyerek ki tudja játszani tehát
hogyha beírjuk hogy szülői felügyeleti
szoftver mit tudom most mondhatok mert
nem fizetnek nekünk de google family
link vagy hasonló az első találat az
hogy hogy kell installálni a második az
hogy hogy kell meghackelni tehát hogy
ezzel ez ezek az eszközök arra valók
hogyha nagyon kicsi gyereknek vagyunk
kénytelenek valami okból telefont adni
akkor ezzel együtt adjuk hogy szoktassuk
őt arra hogy ez a telefon ez nem egy
korlátlan játszótér hanem ennek van
helye ideje satöbbi és akkor ott van ez
a szoftver is ez minket támogat de
nagyobb gyerekeknél ez már ez ez már nem
működik sokkal fontosabb kialakítani
bennük a az önkontroll
képességét és és ebben például segíthet
az hogyha hogyha a szülők itt nagyon
világos határokat rajzolunk tehát azt
mondjuk hogy hogy a ne haragudj áll de
este 8-kor a szobádból ki kell hozd a
telefont és le kell tedd a mit tudom
nappaliba tölteni
az még jobb hogyha a szülő példát mutat
és neki is van ébresztő órája és nem a
telefonjával akar feltétlen feltétlen
ébredni
radikálisabb gyermekorvosok azt is
mondjá ez miér bajha telefonjával ébred
a mert a gyerekben azt a benyomást kelti
hogy ez a telefon ez egy
nélkülözhetetlen dolog és apa élete
megállna és nem mehetne munkába hogyha
nem lenne neki telefonondjó
igen de hogy de hogy ezt ezt ezt be
lehet mutatni hogy nem tehát nem azért
nem az van tehát hogy nem reggel nem az
kell legyen az első dolog amihez
hozzányúlunk van vannak olyan
gyerekorvosok akik azt mondják mondjuk
ez inkább az amerikai realitásokra
alkalmazható ahol hatalmas házban laknak
az emberek hogy a gyerek az eszközét
semmikor ne vigye be a gyerekszobába
amikor egy felnőtt otthon van tehát
akkor azt az időt ugye töltsük a felnőtt
közelébe a beszélget ne hogy gyerek feje
bubját lássuk csak a az ajtórésen
keresztül hány éves korban adhatunk
telefont
igen ez egy ilyen nagyon örök kérdés és
és minden szülői elő adáson vagy
workshopon előhozódik igazából erre van
egy ajánlás egy debora heitner ajánlás
amire szoktunk hivatkozni és ami közel
áll hozzánk hogy nem az számít hogy hány
éves a gyerek hanem az hogy mennyire van
felkészülve a szülő mert ugye ahogy
csila is szokta mondani hogy a
telefonnal együtt a a világ minden jó és
minden rossz dolga ugye a gyerek kezébe
meg zsebébe kerül és onnantól kezdve
nincs olyan téma ami ami tabu otthon
tehát ahogy a telefon otthon van
onnantól kezdve már megvan az esélye
arra is akár hogy szexuális jellegű
tartalmak zaklatás mindenféle akár
lejárató tartalmakkal trash tartalmakkal
káros influenzerekkel találkozhat és
ezért nagyon nagyon fontos hogy akkor
erre fel kell készüljön a szülő is hogy
ezekről a kényes témákról mostantól
akármikor beszélni kell sőt jobb hogyha
egy kicsit megelőzzük mi a a dolgokat és
az ő szintjén megfogalmazva már behozó
nak témák volt olyan tapasztalatom még
régebb már öt évvel ezelőtt ezelőtti
történet hogy hogy első osztályba hívtak
igaz ott már nem volt szó prevencióról
ami az én területem de az volt az eset
ami kapcsán megkerestek hogy tableten
került pornófilm az első osztályba be
úgyhogy igazából nem a gyerek ebben a
helyzetben nem biztos hogy teljesen
tudja vagy értelmezi a látott képeket de
hát de nem kell mondanom igen hogy
milyen hatása van és természetesen
hatása van de hogy aog többi gyereknek
is megmutatta ezeket a filmeket és és
akkor na hogy a kérdés hogy miért kell a
szülő foglalkoznon a gyermeke online
biztonságával hát amikor eszközt ad
akkor adjon egy támogatást is mellé egy
szabályrendszert ez nagyon fontos
figyelembe kell venni hogy a gyermek
mennyire van erre felkészülve amúgy
ajánlások szerint azt mondják a hat éves
kor alatt egyáltalán ne legyen okos
eszköze tehát ezek a mindenfé
igen ez ezt meg kell próbálni elkerülni
illetve de tegyük fel egy rajzfilmet
megnézhet okos eszközön igen megvannak
erre is vannak ajánlások hogy két éves
korig ne legyen egyáltalán képernyőidő
háromtól öt éves korig napi maximum egy
óra és magas minőségű tartalmakat
fogyass szülő által szűrt és lehetőleg
felnőtttel együtt vag hogy ez közös idő
legyen a
képernyőidő azon felü vagy legalább
gondolom a a szülőnek az atmoszférájá
tehát tegyük fel hogyha főz a az anya
otthon de figyeli hogy mi történik
jlétében igen igen még mesék közé is
tudnak bekeveredni olyan káros tartalmak
ami első látásra mondjuk pepa malacnak
tűnik de valójában mondjuk valami
tényleg nagyon durva erőszak van benne
ami mondjuk egy három-négy éves
gyereknek nem értelmezhető jól olyan meg
ő magábó tizni amilyen irányba most
elindult a legújabb rajzfilmeivel oda
becsempészett ilyen vog tartalmak
amelyeket nem ért a gyermek hogy mi
törén nem lehet téma nélkül hagyni tehát
hogy ezekrő kell beszél ez újabb újabb
jó téma hogy beszélni a családi
értékrendről hogy egyes emberek ezt
miért látják ennyire fontosnak és ezzel
szemben mi mit
gondolunk úgy is lesz egy időszak amikor
a kortársak véleménye fontosabb de azzal
szoktuk szokták biztatni a
pszichológusok a szülőket hogy azért a
megfelelő időben elvetett magok azok
egyszer csak szárba szökkennek sokszor
van egy ilyen apájos vagy nem aszájos
bocsánat időszak amikor szülő úgy érzi
hogy elves
de azok a dogok visszajönnehát hogy mind
ez hány éves korb minden szó várható ez
a a a visszajövés nem a az a aájos időak
hát a tíédzserkor téder 13 éves kort
igen
igen igen azt szokták mondani hogy mikor
adja a telefon hogy legyen a gyerek
felkészülve legyen a család felkészülve
a gyerek felkészülésse az például az
hogy van-e felelősség ézete tehát tud-e
otthon például rá lehet-e bízni egyszerű
dolgokat vásárlást nem tudom segíts
attól fü hogy milyen élethelyzetben él a
másik az hogy hogy tudja az érzelmeit
menedzselni hogyha ugye minden gyerek
máskor érik hogyha azt látjuk hogy
mindenre tönkremegy mindentől kikészül
van vannak ilyen ilyen életkori
sajátosságok minden gyereknél lehet ez
korábban vagy kicsit később ha mindenre
megsértődik ha mindenből drámát csinál
akkor akkor ne adjunk már neki olyan
okos eszközt még még kevésbé okosat se
amin akár szöveges üzenet ben a
barátnőivel próbálnak kapcsolatot
tartani mert hogy ott ott már két perc
alatt kialakul a káosz és jönnek a
sértőbántó satöbbi tehát hogy tanítsuk
meg előbb a gyereket arra hogy a maga
életkori sajátosságainak megfelel de
tudja moderálni az
érzelmeit tudjon jól kommunikálni tudjon
bocsánatot kérni ezek ilyen alapvető
alapvető dolognak tűnnek de nem minden
gyereknek van meg ez még 10 é ami amit
így megértettem talán az az hogy minden
egyes tágit tásnál amikor több
lehetőséget kap ugyanúgy több
felelősséget is kapjon és hogyha ez
párhuzamosan tud menni a egymás mellett
tehát például a házi munkába több
felelősséget vállaljon abban akkor akkor
több mondjom úgy szabadságot is kaphat
pontosan ameriká szintén amerikából
származik ugye ez az őrület is onnan
indult tát azért mind hivatkozunk vissza
mert a kutatások is ott próbálják
utólérni
hamaráb
amerikából van van ez az ajánlás
hogy a szülő amikor gyereknek ad egy
telefont akkor kössön vele egy
szerződést ez a mi kultúránktól egy
kicsit távol áll hogy most akkor leírunk
leülünk és akkor leírjuk hogy jobb
oldalon a szülő kötelessége bal oldalon
a gyerek kötelessége de hogy ezeket a
dolgokat végig kell beszélni nincsen
ebbe semmi ördöngős de ezek a dolgok
hogy mikor használjuk mennyit használod
hol használod milyen felelősségeid
vannak mit lehet ezzel az eszközzel
csinálni mit nem lehet miért adom én az
eszközt miért fontos ez neked mert
egyedüké hazamenj az iskolából men nem
tudom tehát hogy milyen hogy mi az oka
annak hogy én neked hog hogy igen hogy
nem akarsz kimaradni a baráti csoportból
hogy oké akkor rendben van benne vagy a
baráti csoportban de ugye tudod azt hogy
üzenetben mit tudom nem lehet kibékülni
összeveszni remekül lehet de kibékülni
nem úgyhogy jobb ha felhívod a
barátnődát mer személyesen kérsz tőle
bocsánatot is nagyon jó alap igen mert
az üzenetek azok azok ha valaki akarja
akkor mindent az ellenkezőjét érti
nincsen a hangszín nincsen a tónus nincs
az arcunk ott hogy hogy hitelt adjon
annak a szav hog ha magas a bizalmi
szint akkor lehet félszavakban
kommunikálni hogy ha valamiért meg inog
ez a bizalmi szints mond meg hogy
ttinédzser kislányok között milyen
gyorsan meginog ez a bizalmi szint napi
50zer igen tehát hogy ezek ezeket a
dolgokat mind beszélje végig a család és
ugye a felelős szülő az nem feltétlen
egy autoritér szülő tehát nem egy
diktátor szülő aki azt mondja hogy hogy
hogyha a meg észreveszem hogy a szobádba
bevitted a telefont akkor innentől 30
évig nem adom oda egyrészt mert nem
lehet tartani ezeket a hülye szabályokat
ö másrészt meg meg azt is meg kell
beszélni a gyerekel hogy miért volt
nagyon muszáj hogy bevidd mert lehet
hogy van ott egy eset lehet hogy van egy
online zaklatás lehet hogy van egy
utolsó percig halasztott házieladat és
és miután tudjuk azt hogy mi ennek a
következménye ugye a szerződésnek része
az is hogy mi van hogyha nem tartjuk be
a szerződést akkor lehet hogy kiderül
egy olyan helyzet hogy a gyerek azt
mondja hogy de figyelj apa nekem most
mától egy kicsivel több időre volna
ezért és ezért és ezért szükségem és
akkor az a szülő ak aki tényleg felelős
szülő ugye az az az az autorit tehát nem
azt mondja hogy az én tekintélyem é kész
a akkor itt kus legyen mindenkinek hanem
azt mondja jó akkor akkor gyere
beszéljük meg akkor állítunk egy új
szabályt módosítjuk pontosabban a
szabályt de továbbra is van szabály
továbbra is vannak következmények ugye
ezek a autoritatív szülő még magyar
szavunk sincs rá úgyhogy így hogy
tanítsuk meg a szülőket hogy milyennek
kell lenni hogyha nincsenre egy jó
magyar szó ugye ez az a szülő aki
empatikus kedves megértő ő érdeklődő a
gyerekével de ugyanakkor szigorúan
számon számon kéri a szabályokat hát én
ezt amúgy egy céges kontextusban ilyen
vezetett autonómiának hívnám tehát hogy
nemontosan hogy van egy autonómia de van
egy vezetés is és egy vezetett autonómia
a kettő ötvezete tökéletesen ugyanaz a
telefonok kapcsán nekem még az jut
eszembe ugye hogy mikor és hogyan kapjon
telefont amit én fontosnak tartok
kihangsúlyozni hogy próbáljuk meg
elkerülni azt hogy túlpozicionáljuk a
készüléket tehát hogy lehetőleg ne egy
ilyen nagy esemény keretében legyen az a
leghatalmasabb ajándék hanem mert azzal
máris egy olyan üzenettel indítunk a
saját okostelefonnál hogy hát ez egy
annyira fontos és értékes és egy egy
igazi kincs hanem valamilyen hétköznapi
helyzetben kapja lehetőleg hát akinél
már másképp történt most már ezen ezen
érdemes így elgondolkodni hogy volt-e
befolyással a a kapcsolatra de hogy
fontos hogy azt az üzenetet közvetítsük
hogy ez egy kommunikációs eszköz amit
így ahogy elsoroltuk erre és erre és
erre használunk és hogy nem feltét kell
egy nagy eseményhez kapcsolódjon az hogy
te ezt megkapod hanem mert mert mi így
akarjuk mert mi megbeszéltük és mert úgy
érezzük hogy most már szükségünk van rá
de hogy ne legyen mondjuk a büntetés
tárgya ezt ezt meg kell valahogy
próbálni elkerülni tehát hogy hétköznapi
helyzetekben történő kihágásokért ne
legyen az a büntetés hogy elvesszük a
telefont vagy nincs internet satöbbi ez
is lehet mert ugye a tiltott gyümölcs a
aek
igen és ezzel abba az irányba
terelhetjük a dolgot hogy ha edig ig
mondjuk kialakítottunk valamilyen
bizalmi közeget akkor a félelem miatt
hogy hogy hogy fél attól hogy elveszik a
telefonját nem fog merni megosztani
például olyan dolgokat hogy zaklatták és
erre egy 2018-as eu kits online kutatás
is van ahol romániai gyerekeket is
kérdeztek és ott is kiderült hogy nagyon
sok gyerek azért nem meri elmondani a
szüleinek hogy mondjuk nyíltan szexuális
tartalmakat kapott vagy zaklatták őt az
online térbe mertogy attól félnek hogy
az lesz a következménye hogy elveszik a
telefonjukat tehát hogy val hogy ezeket
a mondatokat próbáljuk meg valami mással
helyettesíteni
igen hát a a tartalmakkal
kapcsolatban azt látom megint változott
a világunk mert az online világ
valójában örökké fenntartja azt a
tartalmat amit valaha kiadtunk magunkról
és ilyen szempontból nem csak a most
végig csak fiatalokról beszélgettünk
mert én kérdeztem a fiatalokra rá de
tudom hogy édesanyám te is fogod nézni
de a a az egyik alkalommal volt
édesanyámmal egy olyan vitánk ami amikor
kirakott rólam és az unokákról egy képet
az én engedélyem nélkül és am az ő érve
az volt hogy ezek az én unokáim ez az
egyik és a másik az hogy a az én képem
mivel elküldted nekem ez most már az
enyém és kirakta a közösség és akkor
persze volt egy vita ebből és akkor
visszavette és akkor kellett
szabályokat hozzunk hogy valójában én
akkor fogok küldeni legközelebb képet
hogyha betartjuk ezeket a szabályokat
nagyon nehezenre esett amúgy meghúzni
így a határokat de kellett realizáljam
és amúgy a nem nem a családi körben még
több helyen megtörtént ez úgyhogy
úgyhogy tényleg nagyon kellemetlen volt
ezt ezt a ezeket a én egy konfliktus
kerülő személy vagyok amúgy tehát ezeket
nekem így megharcolni mindig nehezemre
esik és majd v gyanítom hogy a
gyermekeimmel is majd végig kell járjom
hogy minden egyes tartalom örökké fent
lesz és a baráti körödben így fog
szétterjedni hogyha valami olyan dolgot
osztasz meg valakivel aki azt hiszi csak
veled és csak it olyan nincs mert
valójában én emlékszem hogy
gyermekkoromban pornográf tartalmak egy
lányról a a az ismerősi körömbe
szétterjedtek futótűz szerűen és
valójában egy életre szerintem
tönkretették annak a lánynak az életét
mert mert egy nagyon-nagyon
kiszolgáltatott pozícióban büntetésből
ráadásul tehát bosszúból megosztották és
és mindenki ezt látta és ráadásul akkor
még a közösségi média annyira nem is
volt elterjedve mint most üm úgyhogy
talán ez az egyik gondolat amit egy
kicsit boncolgatnék az az az hogy mi is
egy online tartalom mi is egy digitális
tartalom hogyan kell gondoljunk egy egy
digitális tartalomra amit pillanatok
alatt meg tudunk el tudunk készíteni egy
egy egy szelfi videó vagy egy kép vagy
egy szöveg mi mi az van van-e ilyen
ilyen jó tanácsotok ezzel kapcsolatban
hogy hogyan gondoljanak a fiatalok vagy
akár az idősek vagy a szülők az a a
digitális tartalomrá van egy van a nagyi
szabály ugye vannak a van van pont
bocsánat pont ilyen nagymama jött szóba
de hogy a a nagyi szabály más mást
jelent azt jelenti hogy te tegyél olyat
a netre amit a nagymama mamádnak nem
mutatnád meg vagy nem szeretnéd hogy a
nagymamád lássa aztá ennek vannak
variációi én az óriás plakátos szoktam
mondani még hogy egy hatalmas nagy óriás
plakáton kell elképzelni ami ki van
helyezve a város
központjába akár az üzeneted akár a
képed és és hogyha oda kimernéd akkor
akkor ez prevenciónak természetesen
nagyon jó és fontos is hogy elmondjuk
ugyanakkor minden gyerek kipróbál
valamit ami nem oké szerintünk
ez ebben is nagyon fontos hogy a
szülőrésen legyen mert igaz ugyan hogy
örökre és garantáltan tartalom ez
továbbra is így van sajnálatos módon nem
távolítható el az internetről de hogyha
ilyen ilyen szempontú bajba került egy
gyerekünk hogy egy szexting ugye a
szülők szerintem tudják most már hogy mi
a szexting de ha nem akkor mondom én
hogy a szexting az egy szexuális
tartalmú szelfi jellemzően küldése saját
magamról saját akaratomból egy egy egy
érzelmi kapcsolaton belül
általában ugye annyira gyakori hogy
ennek neve van tehát a amerika
amerikában vagy angolul a text az a
szöveges üzenet a szext az a szexuális
tartalmú selfie amit amit elküldtök
magamról vagy elküld valaki
magáról jaj tehát a a szöveges
tartalamküldésse az a texténk és akkor
valójában ennek a képnek az elküldése az
a
szexting hogy hogy ez ez borzasztó sok s
sokkad gyakoribb mint amennyire anyai
apai szívünk szeretné hogy ez
megtörténjen ilyen szempontból is nagyon
fontos hogy hogy hogy beszélni a
gyerekekkel erről hogy hogy ez egy
hatalmas nagy baromság és én bízom benne
hogy te nem fogod megtenni de ha ne adj
isten mégis mertogy a hormonok se az
agyad se elborul se a szerelem se nem
tudom egy ilyen dolog megtörténik minél
hamarabb szóljál nekem hogy valamit
próbáljunk ezzel kapcsolatba tenni nem
kioktat nem azt mondani hogy 100szor
megmondtam nem nem tudom micsodaem az
hogy gyere fiam nézzük meg hogy hogy
lehetne kinek ment hova ment szerereknek
szervereken jelenteni megpróbálni
levenni satöbbi illetve hogyha már egy
ilyen dolog megtörtént akkor ne tetézzük
a bajt azzal hogy azt mondjuk a
gyereknek hogy vége az életednek és
akkor innentől téged senki nem fog
fölvenni amit említettél a
fiatalkorodban meg sajnos brigittának is
van ilyen személyes ismerősi köréből
ilyen szomorú tapasztalata ma már ezek
annyira gyakoriak hogy hogy mondjam
kicsit el elhalványult a jelentőségük
tehát hogy hogy nekem konkrétan
középiskolában úgy mondták hogy hát
amikor felhozódik ez a téma hogy jaj hát
ilyesmit már csak az 5-8-asok csinálnak
tehát hogy ezzel most nemrég találkoztam
tehát hogy tényleg ez az igazság hogy
sajnos nagyon gyakori ilen a 912-sök már
a mondták hogy ilyen butaságot már csak
az 58casok csinálnak nagy valszínűséggel
rájuk kell jobban odafigyelni amúgy és
sajnos ugye gyermekpornográfia a
hálózatok az ilyen képeket halásszák
és és felhasználják és satöbbi tehát
hogy hogy hogy lehetőleg ne történjen
ilyen erről feltétlen beszélni kell a
gyerekekkel hogy mennyi rossz dolog
történhet egy ilyen egy ilyen képpel de
mondom ha már megtörtént akkor meg kell
próbálni minden lehető felületen
töröltetni jelenteni hogyha olyan
jellegű visszaélés történt hogy az aki
akinek szerelemből küldte a a lány vagy
a fiú a félmeztelen képet vagy nem tudom
mi és azt tovább küdte az viszont már
bűncsel mny ugye azt is azt is fontos
megbeszélni a gyerekekkel hogy
romániában jelenleg hogyha explicit
szexuális tartalmú kiskorút ábrázoló
képet tartalmaz valaki a telefonján vagy
más digitális eszközén az kettőtől hét
év börtönbüntetés tehát hogy ez azért
azt hiszem n tehát hogyha én a
szerelmemnek küldöm a szerelem mámorába
akkor a másik felet megbüntethetik
amiatt mert hogyha 18 alatti akkor igen
hát igen valószínűleg 18 alatti igen
igen igen igen igen pontosan
tehát erre most már a román törvénykezés
is odafigyel és és vannak esetek a
szerencsére már tudunk erre is példát
mondani csik szeredában is volt amikor
hajnalban a készenléti rendőrség a
konszolidált családoknál rúta be az
ajtót és szedte össze az okos eszközöket
mert egy ilyen felvételt kerestek szóval
ezek ezek ma már gyorsan terjednek de
gyorsan le is nyomozhatók és jó ha tudja
minden gyerek hogy ilyen ilyen dolgokat
véletlenül is elküldik nekik tehát
kéretlenül kapnak ak rengeteg ilyet
sajnos a gyerekek de hogy azonnal szólni
anyának szólni apának és azonnal törölni
azt ketről még egy kicsit szeretnék
beszélgetni de ezt alapelvként
megfogalmaznám hogy nagyon tetszett ah
megfogalmaztat hogy valójában ilyenkor a
szülőnek a feladata az hogy a cinkosa
legyen a gyermekének hogy együtt a
probléma legyen túloldalt és mi ketten
ne kirugaszkodunk a problémának és eh
folyamatosan éreztetni hogy én veled
vagyok együtt érző tehát én veled érzek
együtt nem a nem azzal aki mondjuk erre
rá vett vagy tovább küldte vagy
felbújtott vagy ilyesmi ühüm beszéljünk
egy kicsit a jogi oldaláról is ezeknek a
a digitális biztonsági kérdésekről ezt
már megemlítetted hogy pornográf képeket
kiskorúakról szóló pornográf képeket
vagy tartalmakat ha megkap megtalálnak
nálad és megtalálnak akkor akkor ez
keményen bünteti amúgy ezt
magyarországon vagy más nyugat-európai
országokban is hasonlóan bűtetik igen
igen igen azt hiszem hogy jelenleg ígye
az amerikai törvény az egyik leg durvább
mert ott hogyha ilyen történik akkor
ennek nincs elévülése tehát te bekerülsz
a pedofil regiszterbe gyakorlatilag és
onnantól bárki kikéri rólad az
amerikában másként hívják kziért akkor
ez a dolog benne lesz tehát ez egy ilyen
digitális falu nyelve akkor valójában
amikor ha valami csinálsz a faluban
akkor az az rajtad marad és lesz egy
gunyneved ugyemiatt és val jó érdekes a
hasonlat igen igen itt mindenképp amíg
még tovább mennénk azt fontosnak tartom
kihangsúlyozni és szoktam a gyerekeknek
is meg szülőknek is mutatni ilyen
oldalakat ahol bárki bejelenthet ilyen
jellegű tartalmakat mert mert hogy
tényleg adjunk valami ami valami választ
is mert ezek a helyzetek tényleg napi
szinten előfordulhatnak van
magyarországon a kék vonal alapítvány
akinek a honlapját érdemes felkeresni
ott az email címükre lehet ilyen jellegű
linkeket elküldeni ők felveszik direktbe
a kapcsolatot a szerverrel illetve a
biztonsaggosinternet.hu per bejelentés
oldalon is van egy ilyen bejelentő
felület ahol ha érintett vagyok ha nem
vagyok érintett akár csak rábukkanok egy
ilyen jellegű tartalomra és ott
kiskorúak jogai sérülhetnek akkor itt
elküldhetem és ők nekik tehát hogy azért
jobbak ezek a bejelentések mintogyha én
mondjuk kijelentem igen mert nekik van
24 vagy 48 órájuk és hogy az
alkalmazottaik hogy a szakértők átnézzék
azt a tartalmat és hogyha valóban úgy
látják hogy ez egy gyerek jogaira káros
tartalom akkor ők direktben veszik fel a
kapcsolatot instagrammal tiktokkal
akivel szükséges hogy eltüntessék onnan
és romániában pedig a a az
esk.abus hogyha erre így rá rákeresnek a
szülők gyerekek akkor egy román nyelvű
bejelentő felülettel találkoznak de
igazából mindegy hogy magyarországi vagy
romániai szerverrel oldalra küldjük be
az ilyen tartalmakat merth hogy ők
kapcsolatban állnak ezek a szervezetek
ezek a gyermekjogvédő szervezetek
úgyhogy így most így a jogoknál maradva
igen tehát erről egy kicsit még tovább
szeret ék beszélni és nem csak a
fiatalok kontextusában én azt látom hogy
például a nyugdíjasok körében a az
átverések hihetetlen mértéket öltenek
amikor megkeresik a
nyugdíjasokat mindenféle indokkal
vagy hogy hogy köldjenek pénzt mert az
unokájuk nagy bajban van és hogy v akár
most már hang és videó bocsánat hang és
képtartalmat lehet generálni
ezzel és és a a a az idősebb korosztály
aki nincs felkészülve erre a fajta
személyes támadásra úgymond nagyon tehát
emlékszem az egyik ismerősöm a bankba
dolgozott és mondta hogy ő így
könyörgött hogy ne küldje el azt a pénzt
mert valamelyik füöpszigeteken
valamelyik szerelme akivel az interneten
találkozott szüksége van ahhoz hogy át
tudjon utazni egyik városból a másikó és
mondta hogy ne ne küldje kéri szépen
tudja ez átverés és és nem lehetett
lebeszélni róla szóval itt a jogi téren
mi mi az amit láttok mi mi mi az amire
felhívnátok a figyelmet hogy amikor egy
ilyen bűncselekmény történik és te
önként adod ki a pénzt vagy akár a
bankkártyádnak az adatait és konkrétan
pénzt néha egy életnek a megtakarítását
viszik el akkor mit tud ilyenkor tenni
valaki hát szerintem mindenképp kell
fordulni a rendőrséghez rendőrség
legfeljebb majd mit tudom én hogyha
tényleg önként küdted akkor megállapít
valamit de hátha nem hátha még valahol
megállítható az a pénz hát hogyha ez egy
olyan hálózat amit más is jelentett hát
hogyha egy nagyobb rendszernek a része
mindenképp kell jelenteni tehát én azt
gondolom hogy kell jelenteni ésél
hamarabb a bankhoz hogyha ilyen banki
dologról van szó akkor azt is szokták
javasolni én mondjuk nem vagyok annyira
szakértője ennek a területnek de hogy
minél hamarabb felvenni a bankkal a
kapcsolatot hogyha úgy észleltük hogy
átvertek mert ugye egy bizonyos ideig
azok az összegek még átmenetben mé igen
még átmenetben vannak tehát hogy nincs
még még visszafordítható de hogy minél
hamarabb hogy val hogy leküzdjük ezt a
szégyenérzetet mert amúgy felnőtt
emberekkel is meg olyanokkal is akik
akik foglalkoznak aktívan ezzel a
témával tehát lehet az a trükk aminek
bedőlünk tehát ez bármikor benne van a
pakliban és mindenkivel megtörtéet tehát
senki sem mindenható hogyha hibát
követtünk el vagy hogy tényleg bedőltünk
egy csalónak akkor akkor merjünk na
merjük ezt bevallani hogy hú hibáztunk
és akkor vegyünk egy nagy levegőt hívjuk
fel a bankot vagy épfduljunk tényleg a
rendőrséghez tehát hogy valahogy ezt a
saját szégyenérzetünket meg az ezek való
frusztrációnkal is kell valamit kezdünk
hogy itt van ez a technikai világ és
akkor azt gondoljuk hogy jaj mi nem
értünk hozzá és akkor mi történik
körülöttünk hogy hogy ha ezt leküzdjük
akkor valószínűg egy kicsit higgattabban
tudjuk kezelni és ugye a családok
szolidaritása megint csak hogy nagyinak
is veszünk telefont de akkor nagyinak is
el kell mondani alapvető dolgokat vagy
vagy hogyha ő egy kisebb átverés
áldozata akkor nem lebőgjük ahogy
székelyül mondjuk hanem hanem hanem
tényleg világítsuk próbáljuk kérdésekkel
akár vagy megvilágít együtt hogy mi van
ennek a hátterében és hogy erre jó
odafigyelni mert hogy ez nagyobb
méreteket ölthet vagy pénzbeli csalás
lehet vagy vagy hasonló lehet a ugye itt
a mondtad a fülöpszigeteki szerelmét a
nagymamánk vagy nagytatánnak nem tudom
ugye ezek ez a tipikusan ugyanaz a
jelenség amit téer korban és ami
felnőtteket is érintá most úgy beszélünk
róla minthogyha mi generációnókkal nem
történhetne meg hogy hogy minél kevésbé
érzi úgy egy ember hogy a valóvilágba
számít valakinek annál inkább bedől az
ilyen átverés neek vagy annál inkább
lesz közösségi médiafüggő vagy vagy
hasonló tehát hogy ezeknek mégis ilyen a
gyökere az valahol ott van a a való
életben minden ilen kon igen meg
valójában nincs felkészülve egy olyan
ember aki az egész életét tegyük fel
vagy úgy szocializálódott hogy az emberi
szónak van egy jelentése nincsenek
hozzászokva az anonim pláne az írott
szónak pláne az írott szónak és nincs
nincs hozzászokva ahhoz hogy anonim
módon bárki bármit megtesz mert igazából
ő tehát ez a szociopátiának és a
pszichopátiának amikor instrumentálisan
használom a kör etemet tehát egy ember
pont annyit jelent nekem mint egy fa
vagy egy vagy egy kő az úton tehát egy
egy egy eszköz amit vagy kikerülök vagy
belerúgok vagy vagy valamit kezdek vele
nincs hozzászokva az emberi lélek ehhez
hogy hogy hogy ilyen támadások érik nem
tudom hogy a fiatalabb generáció ez
hozzá fog-e tudni szokni hát azért az
emberiagy képlékeny szerencsére tudunk
tudunk alkalmazkodni ez amit mondott
brigitta hogy jaj ez a csak a kicsikkel
történik meg ez nyilván nem mindig van
így de sok sok szempontból így van tehát
hát azért a fiatalok hát legalábbis egy
része vagy hát reméljük hogy jó része
ilyen szempontból mondjuk a középiskolás
korosztály felkészültebb felkészültebb
legalábbis de hát ugye mindig lesz egy
réteg aki akihez akinek aki nem kap
értékrendet aki nem kap mást mint ami az
online világban van és információt igen
és ők ők ők nyilván továbbra is ki
vannak téve veszélynek mindegy hogy
milyen fiatalok még az jutott eszembe
akár az idős akár a gyerekek
korosztályát tekintve vagy egyáltalán
hogy ez e a két
célcsoportot nézzük hogy hogy ugye a
figyelem megint nagyon-nagyon fontos
hogy mennyi figyelmet és időt tudunk
fordítani úgy a gyerekekre mint a az
idősebb korosztályra hogy mennyi időt
töltünk velük és hogy mennyi időt
töltünk azzal hogy ezt a digitális témát
egy kicsit beépítsük hogyha aktuális ez
ugyanúgy érvényes szerintem a
nagyszülőkre is hogy velük is
elbeszélgetni ezekről a dolgokról érezni
hogy tőlünk kapnak figyelmet nem
feltétlen kell a a fülöpsziget eki a
szerelmüktől várják azt az odafigyelést
tehát hogy sokszor amúgy itt rejtőzik a
a nyuszi hogy hogy hogy valamilyen
hiányt pótolunk a közösségi médiával és
és hogy ezekre a hiányokra érdemes
nagyobb hangsúlyt fektetni
igen hát a a van van-e még valami amit
jogi téren megemlítenétek mielőtt a
következő témára megyek nem vagyunk
nagyon nagy jogász jogász szakértői de a
nyilván az amikor már jogi sikra kell
terelni az már a nem a prevenció tehát
hogy ott már hát a prevenció része az
hogy tudjuk azt hogy hogy tudjuk hogy
van ez persze jogi felelőség a milyen
képek vannak a a telefonomon az az
valójában jogilag ez egy ez egy
elszámolható kell legyen meg ugye ez is
amit mondtál hogy kitehetek-e egy képet
amit nekem elküldtek h nem tehetek ki
tehát a képnek mindig az a tulajdonosa
aki a képen rajta van hogyha erről a
jogáról nem mondott le írásban ugye
erről szól a gdpr tehát hogy ezt ezt
azért ez megint egy ilyen dolog amit ha
nincs is benne a kultúránkba de ezt kell
tudni alapvető szinten vagy alapszinten
tényleg a személyiségi jogokról meg ez
hogy tényleg kié a kép ilyen jellegű
dolgokról érdemes beszélni illetve akár
a kommentek szintjén is most vannak ugye
külföldön is ilyen kezdeményezések hogy
már kommentek szintjén is hogy hogy akár
a a mondjuk a valami raszista
kijelentésekért is számonkérhető vagy
tehát egy kommentér is vagy gyűlölködés
vagy fel bújtás vagy az élet ellenzóló
vagy fenyegetés satöbbi tehát hogy hogy
azért az írásban történő leírt
dolgainkért is hogyha az valamilyen
törvényt sért akkor felelősséget kell
vállaljunk tehát hogy hogy vannak ilyen
ilyen területei
ennek hogy ne csak negatív konnotációja
legyen ennek a beszéd mármint hogy
szeretnék minél több pozitívumot is
behozni nyilván szeretem a a
megvilágítani a problémákat de az egyik
dolog amit észrevettem magamon az elmúlt
egy-két évben it trend ként lá kíváncsi
vagyok hogy nektek mi a tapasztalatotok
az az hogy egyrészt bennem is de úgy a
környezetemben is észreveszem azt hogy
egyre inkább vágyunk a valós tartalmakra
tehát már az írott szöveg önmagában nem
izgalmas számunkra hírlevelet kiolvas
manapság de a másik az hogy már a
felvétel tehát a a a a a megvágott anyag
is elvesztette a hitelét tehát ezért jó
a podcast formátum ami egy vágatlan
hosszú formátumú anyag mert mert az
emberek ezt nézik folyamatosan mert egy
hitelességet ad annak hogyha nincs
megvágva de ennél még hitelesebb az
élőanyag tehát hogyha valaki egy ilyen
live
em említettétek a twitchet hogyha egy
ilyen élő felvételen szerepel és a és az
az érzetünk hogy egy egyszerre történik
tehát tudunk kommentálni válaszol od a
személy ezek egyre népszerűbbé kezdtek
minthogyha kollektívan az emberiség
egyre inkább vágyik az igazi tartalmak
iránt ami értékes és minthogyha elég
lett volna a szemétből minthogyha elég
lett volna k húy megcsömörölt volna ugy
ahogy már a 9-12-es korosztály azt
mondja ezeket már csak a a azok
csinálják a az 5-8asok de talán
minthogyha a a a kiingott a az inga
kiingott volna az egyik irányba is
mintha kezdenénk visszamenni egy
normalitás irányában is és egy talán
minthogyha egy ilyen reméysugarat látnék
nem tudom ti láttok ehhez hasonlót hát
ez erről most nekem a nagy dilemmáim
jutnak eszembe igazából de valamennyire
egyet tudok ezzel érteni lehet hogy
azzal jön egy idejűleg e ez hogy ahogy
telik az idő egyre több információnk van
ezekről a a dolgokról mert amikor én
2016-ban elkezdtem ezzel a témával
foglalkozni annyira nem is volt igény rá
vagy volt de úgy úgy elvolt mindenki
ezzel a témával annyira nem vettük
komolyan aztán káb
2018-19-től rohamosan megnőtt a sebesség
hogy hogy beszéljünk erről egyre több a
téma egyre több a podcast egyre több a
videó amiből tudunk informálódni és hogy
tényleg egyre egyre több információ és
lehetőség áll rendelkezésünkre hogy akár
ingyenesen is fejlesszük magunkat és
hogy lehet hogy tényleg van egy ilyen
irányvonal én is egyre több olyan
osztállyal találkozom ahol már hallottak
a témákról egyre kisebb osztályokban a
szülők is
már beszélnek róla tehát hogy én is ezt
képviselem hogy hogy lesz egy olyan
időszak amikor nagyon sokan leszünk akik
tudatosan tehát fontosnak tartjuk ezt a
tudatos
eszközhasználatot de lehet hogy ez az
információkkal függ össze ugyanakkor meg
ott van egy másik oldala is ennek hogy a
túl sok információ nem okozza-e azt hogy
most már hú már mennyi már csapból is ez
folyik ugye hogy már megint halljuk
erről már hallottunk ezt már már megint
ez a téma már unjuk és hogy tényleg hogy
nehogy ellenhatást váltson ki az hogy
nagyon sokat beszélünk a a digitális
bizt biztonságról és tudatosságról
mertogy okozhat olyat is hogy hogy akkor
emiatt becsukják az ajtókat az üzenetek
előtt
az az biztos hogy jó lenne és üdvözlendő
lenne ha így lenne hogy az emberek
hiteles tartalmat hallgatnak szívesen és
ez így is van valószínű akkor hogy azzal
a megkötéssel legyen az nagyon releváns
rájuk nézve és ilyen szempontból
borzasztó kutyanehéz dolguk van akár a
szülőknek akár a pedagógusoknak akár a
közösségszervezőknek hogy nem kérdés
hogy a fiatalokat ki kell ebből a
dopamin szerotonin játékból pingpongból
menteni nem kérdés hogy ki kell venni az
online buborékokból nem kérdés hogy hogy
hogy az ott nem oké hogyha ilyen nappal
reggel este apropó az alvászavar is egy
komoly probléma ott vannak de de nagyon
nehéz olyan programot szervezni ami
amire ők úgy gondolják hogy ez érdekes
releváns hiteles
annál nagyobb gratuláció annak akinek
sikerül tényleg
közösségszervezők pedagógusok iskolán
kívüli programok satöbbi a ezeket kéne
szerintem nézni támogatni nem tudjuk az
energiát magunknak megspórolni nem
működnek a régi módszerek hiába mondjuk
azt hogy bezeg a mi időnkben mert ennek
az égegyat a világon semmi értelme oda
kell fordulni beszélni kell a
fiatalokkal meg kell szólítani hármat
négyet is örülni kell hogyha annyi eljön
az offline
rendezvényünkre legalább ő ott van ő jó
helyen van hátha hoz majd mást is
magával ha nem működik valami akkor nem
azt kell mondani hogy fű ez a mai
generáció többet semit nem szervezek
hanem megpróbálni valamit egy egy kicsit
egy kicsit változtatni egy kicsit
módosítani rengeteg a
tennivaló az utolsó téma amit felhoznék
egy kicsit járjuk körbe az a
számítógépes játékoknak a a világa és én
én bevallom sokat játszottam amikor én
ttinnédzser voltam rengeteg időt
töltöttem számítógép előtt de az egy
teljesen más világ volt az még nem egy
ennyire online összekötött nekem még az
én 486-os gépem meg utána a a
gondolhatjátok tehát nem nem adott
alkalmat arra hogy annyira belemélyedjek
mint például most a diablo 4nek a a
komplexitását nézve az egy külön
univerzum csak azzal el lehet tölteni az
életét valakinek hogy abba belemélyedjen
és vanaki el is tölti a
következő adásba pont egy olyan
valakivel fogok leülni aki a pubg
játékba merült el az nem tudom hogy
hallottatok-e róla vagy ismeritek-e én
őszintén szóal nem ismertem ezelőtt egy
hónappal még még csak úgy rákerestem a
mint egy ilyen tipikus y generációs
szülő a fogalmam se volt hogy mit jelent
meg kellett tanuljam kívülről hogy mi
történik ebbe a játékban az se tudtam
hogy telefonon játsszák na most egy
olyan személlyel fogok leülni aki aki
ennek a mesterévé vált itt romániában és
meg őszintén kíváncsi vagyok arra hogy
hogyan tölti az idejét miért csinálja
mennyi időt tölt el mennyi pénzt tölt
költ el ezzel hogyan képzeli el a
jövőjét satöbbi ilyen tipikus felnőttes
kérdéseket fogok feltenni neki de hogy
hogyan látjátok digitális biztonság
szempont ából a számítógépes játékoknak
a világát hogy mik az alapelvek itt mire
kéne egy szülő figyeljen amikor
egyszerűen azt veszi észre hogy egyre
több időt tölt az a a telefonnal vagy a
a számítógépével a laptopjával a a
gyermeke igen ez az egyik amit mondtál
hogy észrevenni hogyha egyre több időt
tölt valaki persze itt is már hogyha az
alapoktól kezdjük akkor a az idő
meghatározása tehát mondjuk amikor
képernyő időről beszélünk otthon és
leszögezünk valamilyen szabályokat akkor
akkor akkor itt ugye a játékokat is be
bele kell egyértelműen érteni a szülők
szempontjából két fontos dologra kell
odafigyelni az egyik az hogy a játékot
amit a gyerek játszik azt felelősen kell
kiválasztani tehát hogy olyan játékkal
játszon a gyerek ami az ő a szintjének
érzelmi szintjének
gyermeklélektani szempontból a
fejlődésének megfelelő erre vannak
különböző jelzők ilyen kis jelek például
a a pegi jelzések ami ami alapján
kaphatunk egy támaszt hogy hogy akkor
nagyjából hány éves korú gyereknek felel
meg az adott játék de vannak különböző
kedv peg ezek ilyen apró jelek ilyen
fekete négyzetben írja hog van ugye zöld
sárga piros van hogy felkiáltój van hogy
írja piros négyzeten hogy 18 vagy épp
egy zöldön hogy 12 satöbbi igen számok
és amellé vannak ezek a tartalomleíró
kiegészítő jelzések amit te mondasz
amely mondjuk egy pók van rajta iss
jelzi hogy mondjuk ijesztő tartalm
tartalom van az adott játékban tehát
ezeket figyelembe venni nagyon fontos de
nem azt jelenti hogyha az adott játékra
valaki rá rárakta hogy ez 12 évesnek
való akkor nem biztos hogy pont az én
gyerekemnek attól még való érdemes után
nézni a youtube-on megnézni valakit a
twitchel aki játssza vagy hasonló hogy
egy kicsit belelássunk úgy ahogy te is
utánanéztél ennek a játéknak megézni
azért a leg jobb oldal ilyen szempontból
angolul van de most már minden
fordítható automatikusan is ez a common
sense media org ahol ahol ilyen
kifejezetten szülői szempontú értékelése
leírása van minden játéknak több
szempont alapján röviden leírják hogy
mit tartam mire számítson a szülő hogyha
a gyerek azzal játszik igen és értékelik
is pont így korosztály szerint
nagyon-nagyon hasznos ez az oldal
például csak egy példa hogy ha a
tiktokra tiktoknak megnézzük a pegy
besorolását vagy vagy egyáltalán amit a
tiktok mond ugye hogy 13 éves kor fölött
ajánlott ahhoz képest ezen az oldalon a
szülők 15 fölött ajánlanák a tiktokot
tehát hogy jó hogyha több forrásból
inspirálódunk ugye tehát ez akkor hogy
felelősen válasszuk a másik pedig hogy a
az időt azt menedzselni kell ez ez két
nagyon-nagyon fontos alapdolog illetve
hogy amikor mondjuk képernyő időről
beszélünk egy játék esetén vagy egy
játékos esetén akkor oké vannak nekünk
saját szabályaink amit otthon
leszögezünk de figyelembe kell vegyük a
játékzabályait is amit a gyerek játszana
tehát hogy érdemes
hát legalább tudjuk hogy mennyi idő
betelik neki amíg egy szintet végig
jáátszik tehát hogy ez egy reális dolog
legyenálni a kilépési pontokat igen tát
ez nagyon jó nagyon jó tetszik tehát
hogy hogy valahogy legyen lekerekítve
hogy adjunk neki lehetőséget hogy hogyha
már tényleg három percre van szüksége
vagy öt percre hogy azt a szintet vagy
azt a küldetést vagy bármit amire
szüksége van befejezve akkor akkor nem
érdemes félb szakítani mert tényleg
akkor akkor csak megerősítjük azt hogy
nem értjük őt igen illetve vannak ugye a
a sok játékos a multiplayer játék amikor
a gyerekek barátokkal vagy idegenekkel
mindkettőre van lehetőség játszanak egy
adott játékot van ahol ők szintet
építenek ezt ilyen teljesítményként is
élik meg hogyha mi kicsapjuk a játékot
félidőn vagy az gyerekünket félidőnél
akkor a bennelik ahogy ők mondják a
társai az a következőben már nem
játszhat merthogy abbahagyta elrontotta
másoknak a játékát illetve hát melyik
felnőtt szereti hogyha felénél van
nyerésre áll a sakba és odajön valaki és
felborítja a saktáblát tehát hő ezt a
gyerekkel megbeszél hogy hogy hány perc
a szint mennyi időre van szükséged ott
viszont muszáj letenni üüm amikor amikor
a szint véget ét vagy amikor hogyha
autoritér módon te felborítod a
saktáblát a legközelebb amikor játszik
és megkérdezik mi történt akkor biztos
hogy azt fogod írni a hülye szüleim
bejöttek és elvették aát az kábé kábé
ennyire gyors leépíteni a bizalmat hog
hát vagy nem otthon fog játszani vagy
becsukja az ajtaját vagy elmegy a
barátjához és ott fogja játszani és
durvább játékot fog játszani mint amit
otthon játszana ugye itt az idő szakott
tehát hogy ez ezek ezekben ezek rengeteg
időt
igényelnek van van ennek pozitív
aspektusa is vagy hogy mondjam van már
van már az elsort amiről talán a szülők
hallottak azok különféle számítógépes
játékokból rendezett versenyek ezekből
már világbajnokság már vannak amerikai
egyetemek akik ösztöndíjat adnak
ugyanúgy ahogy a sportolóknak az
elsportolóknak is de hogy a azért az
egészséges egyensúly hogy az életünk mi
mindenből áll és miről maradunk le annak
kedvéért hogy hogy diért építünk az
e-sportba azt azt azért érdemes
megfontolni ugye a az ajánlott képernyő
időket az előbb brigitta mondta de
inkább ezt úgy szok szoktuk mondani hogy
másképp álljon hozzá a szülő nézze meg
hogy a gyerekének adott időszakban adott
életkorba mennyi ideje mennyi időre van
szüksége az iskolába mennyi időre van
szüksége al alváshoz kezdjük azzal mert
az ugye a legfontosabb és egyre
kevesebbet alusznak a gyerekek alvással
iskolába házi feladatra sportolásra
nagymamával nem
tudom mosogatni vagy bevásárolni vagy
berakni a mosogatnivalót a mosogatógépbe
és akkor nézzük meg hogy mi az a mi az a
ami marad képernyőre és annál több ne
legyen lehetőleg ami tetszik az hogy
hogy kiemelted a pozitívumát is a
számítógépes játékoknak mert valójában
van pozitívuma is emlékszem hogy amikor
kéget fejleszt igen sőt vannak kutatások
amik azt mondják hogyha tényleg
megfelelő mértékben használjuk akár akár
még jó hatással is lehet a mentális
egészségre az a kis kiszakadás tehát van
van egy ilyen útmutató gamer gyerekekhez
az
nmhhhoz köthető kiadvány érdemes
rákeresni a google-be ingyenesen
elérhető egy teljes pdf-ben és ott is
ott nagyon sok ilyen kutatás van ami ami
alátámasztja hogy hogyha megfelelő
határokkal játszuk akkor akkor tényleg
nagyon sok játékfejlesztő is lehet ott
írnak amúgy erről az esportról is
úgyhogy ajánlom a szülőknek is hogy egy
kicsit így nézzenek utána meg hogy hogy
tényszerűen statisztikailag hány
százaléka a gamereknek aki mondjuk függő
is tehát hogy attól hogy valaki még
sokat játszik még nem biztos hogy függő
tehát ahhoz képest viszonylag
alacsonyabb azok akik már szélsőséges
módon tehát hogy tényleg a hétköznapi
dolgaikat teljesen hátrahagyva akár
alapvető akár tisztálkodás kapcsolatot
fönart ilyen saját tapasztalatból is
ugye nekem is van egy kis tínédzser fiam
aki ő is szeret nyilván játszani meg
játszanos sokkal többet hogyha tehetnié
hogy hogy hogyha azt látjuk hogy hogy
van egy játék amit nagyon alaposan
körüljártunk megnéztük a common sense
median azt írta hogy 15 akkor mondtam
hogy nem lehet akkor erről még egy
csomót tárgyaltunk akkor megnéztük hogy
van a sztory mód és van az online mód
szóval na elég sokat maceráltunk és ő
végül elkezdi játszani nyilván nagyon
beszívja a játék ha azt látjuk hogy hogy
hát most már nem nagyon akar eljönni egy
hétvégére velünk mert mert hogy akkor
kimaradna egy nap a játékból akkor akkor
beszélni erről és azt mondani hogy na
ide figyelj most akkor ez tényleg nem
tudunk enélkül élni vagy tudunk mert
hogy néz ki nem tudunk nem tudunk
nélküle élni akkor akkor akkor az azzal
valamit kell kezdeni próbáljuk ki hogy
két nap nem játszol ez ilyen ez ilyen ön
tehát ilyen mint a böjt hogy hogy egy
kicsit helyreerakjuk a dolgokat a
fejünkben hogy ja tényleg van élet a
ezen kívül is és akkor következőben
lehet könnyebb lesz letedni vagy
könnyebb lesz ezt az egy napot kihagyni
mert például az egyik nagyon tetszik ez
is amit mondtál például az egyik dolog
amit észrevettem ígye az online
kollaboratív játékokban hogy spontánul
egy etika amúgy amúgy ami a világban is
érvényes elkezd ott is élni ez egy
spontánul hogy ha te is te is vagy a
legjobb a játékba ez nem egy jó
stratégia hogy mindenkit legyőzök és
egyedül próbálok virítani mert valójában
egy idő után azok akik kevésbé jók
ketten összefognak és levadásznak téged
csak azért mert arrogáns vagy meg kell
tanuljon valaki úgy az élen járni hogy
közben segíti a a azokat akik kevésbé
kompetensek tehát egy ilyen belső
hierarchia kialakul ahol az arrogancia
nem egy nem egy jó útmutató a a nyerserő
nem egy jó útmutató hanem egy belső
etika alakul ki csimpánzoknál is
kialakul egy ilyen belső etika
függetlenül attól hogy tehát azt
gondolnánk hogy a legnagyobb legdurvább
vadállat alfaahím az amelyik uralja a
csimpánz csapatokat és kiderül hogy nem
mert valójában egy rossz napján két
betéttársa szétszedi darabokra mert
annyira erősek úgyhogy a leg amit
észrevettek az az hogy a a csimpánzok
között is kialakul egy spontán belső
dinamika ahol azok akik a leginkább a
gyerekekre a nöstényekre figyelnek és
egy egy belső dinamika kialakul azok a
legsikeresebb alfahémek és valójában a
játékon belül is ezt pont a pubg során
vettem észre hogy pár mondatból rájöttem
hogy hoppá ez nem olyan egyszerű azért
ami ott történik hanem ahhoz hogy én a
hierarchiába felkerüljek én valójában
egy csomó alkotárgyát
kellett kiharcoljam és gyakorlatilag az
én pozícióm az valójában egy kollektív
pozíció ahol engem felszavaztak mértóá
kell váljak ahhoz hogy a játék kognitív
és társas kompetenciákat is fejlesztenek
a jó játékok kétség kívül itt ugye a
veszély az az szokott lenni hogy mennyit
vagy minek a róvására igen igen és é
észre kell venni mert ugye nagyon
gyakran az van hogy egy játékban hogyha
mondjuk én a hétköznapi helyzeteimben
tegyünk tegyük fel mondjuk iskolai
környezetben nem igazán jutok vezető
szerephez vagy egy olyan pozíciót töltök
be akár az osztályon vagy a közösségemen
belül ahol ahol elnyomnak akkor
tehát hogy fokozott veszélye van annak
hogy mondjuk kialakul az hogy azért
húzódok és azért kötődök nagyon a
játékokhoz hogy ott viszont én lehetek
vezető ott irányíthatom én a dolgokat az
az én kis világom és hogy ezért érdemes
figyelni ez amit az elején említettem
hogy ha növekedik a a játékkal eltöltött
idő tehát hogy már akár szélsőségesen
sok időt tölt el valaki a játékkal akkor
akkor érdemes megtudni azt hogy itt
valóban arról van szó hogy mondjuk
kialakult nála egy függőség vagy ezzel ő
elnyom eg hétköznapi
helyzetbenéőémát tehát hogy igazából
odaekül és hogy lehet hogy megoldjuk a
hétköznapi problémáját vagy elkezdünk
arról beszélni és arró megoldásokat
találni és akkor megoldódik maga a
szélsőséges használathoz kapcsolódó
probléma is tehát hogy nagyon összetett
dolgok nem igazán egyszerű megfejteni
ahogy egyik téma se volt egyszerű a
végére érkeztünk most egy nagyon
izgalmas beszélgetésnek még biztos hogy
lenne pár terület tényleg egy pár
terület még soroljunk fel amiről nem
beszéltünk és talán egy következő
alkalommal hogyha alvás alváspréma alvás
megegvonáséma igen a a beauty appok vagy
egyáltalán azok a a felületek vagy
filterek és ezeknek a használata
használata meg hatása nekem ez jt esem
onaklatás igen konkrétan kitérve jó hát
kedves nézők hogyha tetszetted az adás
akkor kérlek hagyjatok egy kommentet
lájkoljátok osszátok meg és segítsetek
minket abban hogy minél több ember hez
eljusson ez a a az adás valamint hogyha
tényleg tetszett és szeretnétek ezekről
a témákról is beszélgetni akkor pár
hónap múlva még egyszer leülhetnénk
beszélg engem nagyon érdekelnek ezek a
témák és hogy milyen trendek mennek
talán egy kicsit ezekről is
beszélgethetünk hogy aktuálisan milyen
trendek
mozgatják a háttérben a fiataloknak a
figyelmét és nem csak a fiatalokét tehát
minden korosztályról érdemes beszélgetni
nekem mindenesetre nagyon hasznos volt
egy jó pár olyan gondolatot adtatok
amire nem gondoltam és az első dolog az
lesz most szerintem a feleségemmel
miután
este hazaérkezünk és egy kis szó tudok
váltani az hogy hogy szeretnék szeretnék
egy házirendet beállítani ami legelőször
is saját magamra fog vonatkozni mert
érzem azt hogy befolyt a világomba az
amit nem szeretnék befo és igazából
mondták nem nem az van hogy nem tudtam
ezt de most így így egy újult erővel azt
azt látom hogy hogy ez nem egy játék ez
és nagyon szimpatikus ahogy mondod hogy
hogyha magunkkal kezdjük az nagyon
hiteles a gyerekeknek és lehet hogy
tőlük fogsz okos tippeket kapni arra
vonatkozóan hogy hogy tudod te a saját
digitális életedet jobban menedzselni és
akkor már lehet a következő kérésünk az
hogy na de akkor nézzük át nektek is
hogy hogy mennyi bár nálad még kicsik a
gyerekek de igen hát a k kisfiam gyakran
mondja hogy a a munkatestvéreiddel ne
beszélj megint
drá köszönöm nagyon szépen hogy itt
voltatok mi köszönjük a
meghívástön szép napot nektek nektek is
ha tetszett ez a műsor akkor iratkozz
fel kérlek a csatornánkra ezzel tudsz
támogatni minket köszönjük a vckker
kávéközösségnek a jó kávéért az
ötvösudvarnak a helyért valamint a
bizalomtőkének a támogatásért nékületek
nem jöhetett volna ez létre